this podcast is brought to you by on
it.com
what do you say no [ __ ] come on don't
worry about what i said start this
[ __ ] thing
go donut.com and use codeword church to
get 10 off of all their optimization
products like alpha brand new mood swim
tech immune shroom tech sport it's code
word church to get 10 off
go to irondragontv.com iron dragon tv is
a brand new roku channel
has all of your favorite martial arts
movies from jackie chan the ip man tai
chi hero they have a whole bunch of on
it videos go to on go to
irondragontv.com and he's covered joey
get two free rentals
for all the oil and wax smokers out
there go to naileditlife.com that's
nailed it life they have the premier
vapor pen on the market
for all for all the oil and wax smokers
and you get 20 off of your order if you
use cobra joey diaz
just so everyone knows i'm on a joint
and edible and and
uh mushroom so i just told you don't
wrap yourself up
it's the first thing you [ __ ] do you
tweet it out i didn't [ __ ] tweet
nothing you tweeted all the time also go
to hitesigs.com that's hit letter
esigs.com better tasting longer lasting
the proof is in the vape e-cigarettes
and e-cigars use co-word joey's church
to get 20 off of your order
oh [ __ ]
just when you thought
the day the devil was [ __ ] in the ass
lit on fire and thrown into the same
bowl as obama's and [ __ ] him that
[ __ ] [ __ ] what it's like a
jungle sometimes it makes me wonder how
i keep from going if you didn't know
that i'm reminding you it's like a
jungle sometimes it makes me wonder how
i keep it from going
oh [ __ ] it's the church of what's
happening now jimmy tushu schubert in
the house the flying jewel
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
monday march 6 the church of what's
happening now
stay black and go [ __ ] yourself it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive how
you guys doing today what's the story
with you
what's the story with me there's no
story stop looking at the board i'm
talking to you what's happening how was
your weekend it was great it was great
we uh we didn't do much it was uh just
paul and i we watched house of cards
which is okay not as good as the first
two
seasons and we just went to the gym and
i started doing weights not much
but just to get your joints greased up
right yeah just
just to do uh just
uh with dumbbells and then i did one
machine where you like lean back
and then uh
they had i don't know what it's called
but it's the
bar they put the weights on but they
have weights already like permanently
put on it okay and it was like 50 pounds
i did some curls and
i called you this morning we talked for
like 15 minutes it was really cool and
it's just you know what you need to do
you need to start doing some shrugs
where you hold the dumbbells in your
hand and you shrug and that way when
you're confused you look really massive
like hey how do i i don't know how you
get there
i know you look really massive when
you're confused it's a little workout no
it's good that you're doing this brother
i'm [ __ ] happy that uh
you're giving everything a try you know
you could just do the elliptical so long
before you lose your [ __ ] oh my god i
i still do it
but it's uh it's good to do something
man lift first
when you start lifting you lift first
and then you do the
the cardio because then you burn more
glycogen or something there's a guy
jason who came to the shows in
minneapolis [ __ ] guys like 50s huge
really he looks like a million bucks and
we're talking about dieting and he goes
always do your cardio i have to wait
because now you're going to be burning
the fat even [ __ ] quick and then he
goes and right when you get out of there
that's when your body needs sugar
because as soon as you walk into the gym
if you eat a twinkie nothing will happen
to you you won't gain an ounce your body
burns the [ __ ] sugar right away
right after the gym and rogan was
telling me like when you do a protein
shake after you work out put a tiny bit
of sugar in it everybody needs that
sugar supposedly yeah i don't you know i
don't know much about this there's a lot
of rules like that there's a ton i just
have no idea what they are it's all that
and it's all that i mean you know
everybody there's some guys you want me
to tell what i saw on groupon
if you go to valley village north
hollywood there's a plan that's 315.
lee and they'll give it to you for 99
well there's nutrition
and weights and everything one shot deal
let me tell you something if you're not
going on groupon
before you spend any dough like anything
they have everything on that's why i got
the the the the [ __ ] laser deal to
burn my toenails off
everything i got an hour i got uh four
hours of stretching were you going to
see a guy that stretches you out yeah
yeah yeah
yeah one of the best things i've ever
done because i'm not a flexible guy did
you go yeah the guy's amazing where is
it here is no one's in beverly hills
beverly hills just right over the hill
but the guy works with you for an hour
breaks a lot of stuff you get off an
airplane you go in there and stretch for
an hour i'm telling you man it's great
and i'm day 10 no smokes by the way
congratulations my brother
you've been going back and forth with
this no smoking for years and what
people understand is for a guy like you
after you get off stage you go back to
your room it's not even it's something
that you could control it though like if
you didn't smoke in the daytime and just
smoked after six
once you do a blast though there ain't
no bringing you back
you smoked a [ __ ] cabbage it's like a
lyric that bob
bob secret song smoke today's last
cigarette remember what you
you know i used to smoke two packs of
camels a day and after i pick up a
grandma blow i'd stop at the 7-eleven on
sunset
right there and i get two more packs of
camels and i'd go home and smoke the
[ __ ] two packs in two hours with a
[ __ ] grandma blow just chase
cigarette after cigarette my blood
pressure had to be three [ __ ] 50
overnight i'm glad those days are over
right
it's amazing we survived them bro we're
on the right side what's the matter with
you today nothing doesn't matter when
did you start smoking cigarettes we
never really talked about that before
when i was 31 years old no no no even
older i was 33. yeah i just started i
was about 20 years when i moved to los
angeles yeah for economy stuff that's
that's the same time i started you just
and i was the type of guy you could not
get in the car
i couldn't go in the car with you if you
smoked i would get dizzy from the smell
yeah my mom's the same way i had to
overcome all that [ __ ] and that's why i
did it i was sick and tired of being i
would i would quit jobs i had to touch
an ashtray
like when i was a bartender if i had to
clean an ashtray out it's not going to
work out for you
i didn't even like touching it that
touch on my hands i didn't like it at
all yeah but you imagine you see that
ashtray and you [ __ ] go that [ __ ] is
going on inside my lungs you go [ __ ] oh
my god i mean that's what i wonder what
the inside of my lungs look like and i
have i've been on and off and it's like
you know it's but this time i'm off for
good and i know like i quit for six or
seven years and then i picked it up
again doing a movie yeah in a crazy on a
movie set you just get bored to pieces
and what's going to be one of those it's
a good thing that shit's not addictive
huh yeah [ __ ] it's uh
but it's weird how i put them down like
now it's going to be uh three years in
november for you i remember i remember
when you quit it was right
when she found out about mercy no it was
thanksgiving i went to a kid's house and
i didn't smoke all day and i went to
this guy's house and i bought it back at
cigarettes at six o'clock at night
when i left at eight o'clock there was
four cigarettes left wow no drugs yeah
drinking sodas and just telling stories
getting excited you know that's part of
the patois when you sometimes when you
start smoking like one thing i liked
was uh smoking weed and then writing
jokes while smoking a cigarette because
you're almost on stage
okay you almost yeah it's like it has a
you're smoking something timing like in
your something in your head yeah i don't
know but pretty interesting [ __ ] well i
remember when we first started
working together you were still smoking
cigarettes and
you oftentimes would have like two hits
throw it away go walk somewhere
like you weren't smoking the entire pack
no no i don't it was interesting i don't
like a cigarette after three quarters
then i throw that yeah like those people
that put it out and save it for later i
want to shoot those people
they drive me [ __ ] crazy it's just a
[ __ ] cigarette just smoke the whole
[ __ ] thing and knock it off or take
your puffs and then flick it i smoked
those american spirits it took you
[ __ ] two days to smoke one of those
things and they really taste like ass i
don't think there's nothing in it yeah
yeah there's nothing
winston you smoking winston that they
[ __ ] burns in 20 seconds oh my god
winston camellia the marlboro light
those [ __ ] american spirits they say
you know people get confused like i'll
smoke american spirits and not get
cancer you're still gonna get [ __ ]
cancer yeah you're gonna can you ever
roll your own cigarettes
no no that's too [ __ ] barbaric
that's just too [ __ ] barbaric for me
you know when i was in boulder county
jail that's what they give you they give
you free tobacco and you can roll up
joints and i wasn't smoking that and
people were smoking them and i'm like
this is crazy smoking a lot of filter i
just went to the weed store now they
have glass filters for your joints
which look pretty [ __ ] cool well i
gotta tell you glass filters i mean if
you're gonna smoke any stuff it's better
smoker than a glass than metal you know
what does that do i've never because
i've i've seen people put like little
paper filters at the end of joints i
don't really know what does it even do
anything well it's just for people to be
cool like look at me i put a filter in
i'm sure you did
these [ __ ] momos but now they have
glass and it's it's holds good you know
listen
i'm so old school when you smoke pot
just smoke like they did in woodstock if
you can't smoke like they're doing wood
stocking joints you're doing something
[ __ ] wrong okay somebody shows up
with a pipe and some hash i like all
that stuff too
but they just get outlandish it just
gets out of control it's like a fad
they're always going to be papers and
there's always going to be [ __ ]
who just smoked with a paper but yeah
you know the the new pepsi generation
they want to be cooler than the next guy
those doug benson dudes his friends they
got to be cool in the next dude i will
tell you man those vaporizer sticks that
i mean with the wax and the oil that's
pretty cool you just hit that oh yeah
all that stuff is great but it doesn't
replace that [ __ ] joke no there's
nothing like that you understand when
you could get a [ __ ] yeah when you
could get a lid of the [ __ ] mexican
brown [ __ ] you could roll 20 [ __ ]
joints that i'd sit on the front lawn in
high school [ __ ] it up
unload those [ __ ] things but it's uh
bro hand rolled bro it's it's like the
e-cigarette you're smoking marlboro red
what's an e-cigarette gonna do for you
yeah i'm gonna do [ __ ] i can't wait to
have electronic cocaine that's what i'm
waiting on
electronic cocaine it and you
electrocute yourself and you go to bed
that's it
that's it i can't
everyday they got a new electronic
something
wait electronic heroin electronic coke
electronic wait
it's just around the corner
there's some [ __ ] nerd right now in
his basement
cutting up lines of coke looking for
investors he's got an idea
here's what happens you do it and you
hide the closet you tear up your money
no feelings you lied in the car behind
the closet and now you can hold on to a
light bulb and turn it on like fester
that's what it is you snort coke and you
become electric like that's the [ __ ]
new thing wait electronic met electronic
[ __ ] everything now what's up lisa
does anybody just do anything you know
nobody wants is it all going to be
documented everything i want to say this
though spring and speaking of that i'm
glad we didn't [ __ ] grow up didn't
have all the social media and [ __ ]
around when we were [ __ ] partying
[ __ ] getting me
out of control did you see that thing
about the the kids in the front
sing that racist song i heard something
but it's it's stupid it's like it
happens all the time there's all these
videos out of
people whenever they're gonna get in a
fight like these high school kids they
film it and they put it up on youtube
and then they get in trouble
i i i don't understand taping that
horrible [ __ ] you're doing and thinking
it like when i was in high school the
stuff people got in trouble for was
putting pictures of you with beer up on
facebook like idiots but now people are
putting whole fights up on youtube dude
you know what i've i did i love [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] i mean just even take i mean
taking pictures of your food
i mean just [ __ ] who are you [ __ ]
it's a meal just [ __ ] eat the thing
you know
you're not [ __ ] anything that's why
you can't do nothing guys like i don't i
couldn't imagine being 22 in today's
world like half the fun no it's taken
away because there's always little
[ __ ] [ __ ] with the camera that has to
take it out and tape [ __ ] put the
[ __ ] thing away i cursed whoever put
a camera and a phone
every day of my life every day every
time i see a [ __ ] jerk off taking a
picture
i think whoever put the cam on the phone
i go i can't wait till they catch you
getting your dick sucked by a black
[ __ ] and you're gonna see the mistake
you made you stupid [ __ ] because
you didn't think right and now all these
idiots are gonna take them out for
everything and i'm happy for some things
but some things that just let no there's
dude i'm not even [ __ ] kidding you
bro i mean not not any [ __ ] pictures
but everybody jumps online they gotta
[ __ ] yell but even look just eat your
[ __ ] food and shut the [ __ ] up
nobody needs your yelp
like anybody's gonna read like listen
i wouldn't believe the [ __ ] yelp
if you [ __ ] paid me i have three or
four people right that i know that when
they come to me and they go dog come in
for a second
i went to this restaurant the other day
because i know these people because
they're the type of people that aren't
impressed by glam
yes people who are impressed with the
with the meal with the sprouts on top
i'm gonna pay 54 for a piece of fish
this [ __ ] big yeah to eat with a
bunch of gentiles so i could be seen no
i never first of all the crew i hung out
with always we were professionals in the
lunch special
remember when you move when we were
friends where would we go hoy's walk
howie's walking i always walk i told him
the best special in town i hunt down the
special okay forget all that glam and
all that [ __ ] that's for [ __ ] jerk
off all that [ __ ] dude yelp all that
[ __ ] i won't [ __ ] take listen the
other night and i love your leader that
uh but you don't you're done with me
when it comes to movies do you know
what's that what that chef movie yeah
with john favreau you didn't like that
the what happened the first 15 minutes
let's break it down
what happened the first 50 minutes
nothing
nothing showed him cooking i don't want
to see john fat roll with cooking he
went you know it was an all-star cast up
front five [ __ ] stars in the first 50
minutes my wife finally got up and said
wake me up if something good happens i
just put sons of anarchy and tapped out
yeah
look it's a simple little [ __ ] movie
you know when did it start what time did
it start when did it [ __ ] come to
life it wasn't even about that that's
what i'm trying somebody's relationship
with his kid and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] i
want to see a relationship with a guy
join the boy scouts all right i don't
give a [ __ ] about some fake [ __ ]
movie i got a [ __ ] 72-inch [ __ ]
television with a [ __ ] blu-ray dvd
player show me some [ __ ] blood yeah
and then i don't watch a guy tune in to
watch a guy [ __ ] cook that
was the explosions
ago said a statement at the improv that
i left and i didn't agree with him and
today if i see him
i will shake his hand he said that
america
we're getting fed mediocrity he's right
and we're accepting it is great dude
you know and i told my wife today we
were talking this morning let me ask you
something 30 years from now
when [ __ ] the exorcist comes on
what would you rather watch the exorcist
from 1973 one of the greatest years for
movie ever 73 was the best year movie
that was like a three-year-old or a chef
yeah or chef you can't there's no
there's no relevance in these movies
yeah nothing's gonna make you go but
will john favreau won eight academy
awards a director of that nothing's
gonna make you go back to that film yeah
but you're right because i'll tell you
something at some point i was going i'm
just glad this is it's a little
independent feature sometimes you go
yeah i mean he does the iron man movies
so he could break off and did this i
granted it it fell a little short on a
couple characters but i i enjoyed it
just for the fact that i couldn't i'll
watch it again i couldn't sit there for
four 50 minutes see i'm a [ __ ] cook i
like that i like cooking too i'm [ __ ]
300 pounds
i like to eat i'm the opposite of you
[ __ ] they showed 10 scenes where
he's just cooking it's not even his
hands the grilled cheese i need to see
that i need to see you make a [ __ ]
grilled cheese
for that [ __ ] half a fat kid i need
that [ __ ]
come on guys come on my house right was
the [ __ ] the the chick from [ __ ]
uh the family show say watch the
beginning of it she looked great what's
her name what's up sophia vergara oh my
god bro no i mean
and what it's not
the best movie like i told you to see
kingsman i'm i didn't tell you i told
you when it wasn't going to be terrible
so i'm assuming you saw it and you hated
it i didn't see nothing now i've lost
faith for another 10 years now oh no but
chef i don't know it was
of course you can't compare it to
to scarface or
it's mediocrity and we're paying for
them we're leaving that going that was
okay even though deep down inside we
want to go
that [ __ ] sucked well dude
that sucked and and i've seen this since
i was a kid i saw this but now i see it
you know when i was a kid i hang out
with our osawa i told you guys this and
also used to go to every concert and i'd
be at the concerts behind on the sound
he was one of those kids that got the
t-shirt and told you how good the
concert was i don't the sound sounded
like [ __ ] even the [ __ ] people were
running out of that but otto was on time
nobody could come to you and really tell
you the truth because they feel bad
about spending this short 20.
right that's my point well yeah i mean
do you think the difference is that
there's a lot are there a lot more
movies coming out now because i've
thought about that for a while yes
because there's three four new movies
out every week every week and six of
them right six or seven of them and what
comes out on dvd that you'll never see
you know and those are probably the
better movies right and i think that's
what it is i think it's
yeah then definitely it's not as good as
the 70s which was amazing yeah but dude
but it it's the best of the work of what
we got you're gonna tell me i had ten
people look me in the face and say
birdman was the best movie they ever
watched and i was in until the birds
showed up and started talking
then i gotta go that's it that's it yeah
but there's no
there's nothing to talk about
once the birds showed up me and my wife
look at each other like this is not good
go get a [ __ ] sausage you know but
but i talked to hollywood people like
the first guy i know who the friend i
ain't gonna say his name the first guy
that called me and said that movie is
the greatest [ __ ] movie i've yet to
talk to him since then i know somewhere
in the conversation i'm gonna go listen
next time you send me to a bum [ __ ]
movie
we're gonna have a big [ __ ] problem
okay
well listen i mean the first time you
watch it it does have this effect i
haven't watched it twice i've watched it
twice so the first time you see it
the the the drums by themselves i mean i
thought that was really unique is that
and and the way the camera was used with
those shots those long shots i'm going
you know granted the bird shows up and
[ __ ] ruins the movie but the movie is
called birdman you should be expecting
to see a bird at some point in the
[ __ ] movie i thought he had like a
pigeon or he said pigeons at the park or
maybe he had a [ __ ] parakeet i don't
want some life-sized birds showing up
next to this [ __ ] [ __ ] i just paid
9.50 i got a babysitter me and my wife
out to have a good time yeah i need this
actually yeah but you know why you pay
950 joey to get away from reality where
else are you going to see why no no i
fight i get away from reality when i eat
one of those stars and i ate a piece of
mushroom
i don't need to watch a bad [ __ ]
movie to take me away from me it had
elements it had it had great elements
but not enough to win an oscar
uh
it wouldn't even have survived did you
see uh theory everything the kid that
plays the uh um
hawk of stephen hawkins have you seen
that i gotta go see that now two hours
of a guy in a wheelchair that's what i
want to go see that's what i need
i called einstein yesterday you know my
friend einstein he gave me a [ __ ] 30
minute beating
about his friend
who got hit by a truck this guy's got
the saddest life
first he went to 9 11. he got blown up
he lost his job then they gave him 400.
that only lost at 9 11. himself rocky he
just lost his job a lot of other other
other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other other other then they gave him 400
hours a week to live then he caught a
pneumonia then he caught nymphobia and
they called chlamydia and then one day
he was walking down the street he got
hit by a car and he woke up and his leg
got lost then something else happened
and his wife left him jesus then the cat
blew up and then meanwhile and i'm
sitting there then the duke gets
diseases in the same week that's it
and
pirate
i go einstein give me the gofundme i'll
drop a hundred don't ever call me again
because now i gotta go cut a chicken set
off as a santeria guy no i love that
double gofundme that's the other thing
every [ __ ] time i try to go off the
[ __ ] information highway off-ramp
there's a 20-year-old want to sell me
his virtual bag of oranges hey it's the
cooler with the blender in it stop
[ __ ] putting like comments i don't
give those [ __ ] none i give him
a finger
i beat the horn i give him the [ __ ]
finger that's it and i'm a [ __ ] i give
it to him as the light turns green i
don't give it to him when the light
turns right
but everybody wants to go fund them now
go fund me what have you got these are
sneakers that play guns and roses songs
while you jog you know what go [ __ ]
yourself i don't need this [ __ ] oh my
god it never ends you're not [ __ ]
bill gates looking for seed buddy you're
a [ __ ] you know a douchebag that
wasn't gonna doesn't i know why these
young kids are joining isis huh because
there's nothing
i gotta deal with these [ __ ] dummies
all day agents that don't know how to
pitch you some [ __ ] kid on gmail
that wants to do i wanted you to go to
canada how many times i got to pay i
can't go to [ __ ] canada now they
won't let chris brown you know the
chance of letting me just beat up
brienne i beat up 50 [ __ ] people got
felonies ain't gonna let me into [ __ ]
whatever i lit a [ __ ] crackle on her
wig on fire they definitely got that on
file some [ __ ] wit
well what they do now you're riding in
yourself
that's the entire podcast you're riding
on yourself how many people i went to my
background check thing i've had about
two million background checks this
podcast started did you know that dude
you've read war and peace got nothing
sit down and read the background check
that's right i have one done when you do
like [ __ ] last count we're standing
they send you the [ __ ] thing it's
like this big it's like [ __ ] 60 pages
of [ __ ] they looked into your life they
looked in their head oh they got to
you're going on [ __ ] national
television you're representing nbc you
are an employer maybe they do a
background check on you that guy [ __ ]
told me i still owe milk money from
second grade i mean they [ __ ] have
everything they have a file this big
when you do they send it to you after
they go check it out it's crazy are you
serious oh yeah they won somebody sent
me a question there once for the biggest
loser oh yeah and i filled it out just
as a goof and i sent it back oh my god
oh but nbc still hires me for regular
[ __ ] it's that [ __ ] they run you they
want references and they [ __ ] call
too well no because it's not like for us
because we're in show business we get it
we're kind of been vetted already but
you know some of these other people are
[ __ ] they were
two weeks ago they were america's most
wanted and now they're on [ __ ]
dancing with the stars or whatever you
got so for those reality shows they
really did a thorough now let's say you
went on the last comic standing and you
had a really bad background like me
they're not gonna hire you no they would
hire you but it would become part of the
story
oh i don't give a [ __ ] no yeah you know
well there's there are some stories of
someone doing corner like just terror
not terrible stuff but i think that's
more reality
you know you'll be doing they don't want
to be doing porn you know like
moonlighting is a porn star and all of a
sudden you're on last comic [ __ ] last
middle act standing i think i feel that
i went to do uh nickelodeon uh uh
super ninjas and as
i'm reading
right before i go to read
they slip me something like looking it's
a background check i'm like i'm gonna do
this after the audition i'll go in there
[ __ ] that world up and then give them
this on the way out of the audition
right so one day i [ __ ] their world up
and i come out and i asked lady why do
you want a background check she just
come here because we caught one of our
producers and that thing that show leave
it remember that show uh to catch a
predator oh yeah
there's a guy from nickelodeon got
caught so nickelodeon was in deep [ __ ]
so i had to do a background check when i
gave him the background check i said it
was nice meeting you because i'll never
see you again
sure enough they gave me a recurring
role three episodes with the background
check
yeah but they're looking for they're
looking for [ __ ] if you get caught in
a park with a [ __ ] whip yeah and a
nazi helmet with a bag of candy you know
what i'm saying with little german boots
to give the kids
you know they ain't looking for you if
you stole the kilo not undercover
that's that's [ __ ] all you know
dui big deal like you know tax lead
nothing you know it's like make sure you
want to make sure you're not finger
banging it's like that scene in easy
money look at that kid look at the kid
look at the way that man bounces that
kid on his lap that's love and listen
the lady comes with a cop excuse me
excuse me is that your kid and he goes
no he just jumped on my lap and started
bouncing up and down the cop goes let me
see some id goes it's in my rain jacket
that's a classic but it's not rodney and
joe paschie talking
it's over there nobody's ever done that
before right they're in the conversation
and i'm saying you're here with the
pervert
rodney's like look at the way the kids
look at the way the father bounces that
kid and they cut up close to and they
kind of cop comes to the lady and goes
what happened what's going on there you
know this kid he goes i don't know this
guy he just came over and started
jumping on my lap and the cop goes let
me see the identification he goes it's
in my other rain jacket that's the joke
and you see rodney looking at [ __ ]
uh joe pesci wow that's great so what's
up with you you already seen the devil
[ __ ] you said yeah you gave me 125
milligrams plus that's 25. no it's not
those are the 20 at least give me the
credit when i get when i do it those are
the 25s no they're not there's no
there's no 25s maybe that one i talked
to a guy i have a source now you talked
to a guy who who knows how many
milligrams on these and then [ __ ]
those [ __ ] and then we had the
mushroom stuff which is fun
he talked to the guy behind the guy
behind the guy there's always a guy how
was the last comic uh experience for you
from did they contact you and say well
you know what the thing is man i just i
i was uh i just you know it was like one
of the three i had like a three a day
thing i had an audition
for uh a tv show i had a [ __ ] radio
interview in that downtown and i had the
sweet swing back and i just thought well
[ __ ] i'll just do it i i it was just
like a busy day and i'll just stop
popping just for goof and they invited
me to be part of it and i said okay well
it's an opportunity to just see what
kind of exposure you get from it and
and uh you know i'd always put david
tells comedy on the ground in the can so
i knew and so i did that they invited me
to 100 they invited me to be top 28 they
invited me to the top 10. i said [ __ ]
this is great i had a it was it was fun
man it was great and i just saw wanda
sykes at the sushi joint by my house and
she came up she gave me a big hug i mean
it was a success for them they brought
it back i thought what they wanted to do
is kind of kind of respect it a little
more this year i thought they they
wanted to put the comedian's display on
process it wasn't the the comedian's
process on display wasn't stupid i mean
they kind of you know made you get there
with then then it became real housewives
the last comic standing but still i mean
i thought it was they did it better this
year than they've done in previous years
that was my
and uh it was good man it was great to
be part of it there was a lot a lot of
guys rocky laporte's been doing it
forever dc benny's been doing it forever
you have uh nikki car's been doing it
for a long time rodman's been doing it
for a long time you guys got guys like
lachlan patterson and monroe martin you
know and aydah rodriguez i mean you know
these people have been around for a
while doing it you know
so it was it was nice that everybody
everybody got a bump out of that and and
and uh everybody's out there you know
whereas before some guys are going i
gotta go to [ __ ] real estate school
these guys have now got a little second
second win so it's good it's i think
it's good for comedy i think it was good
for stand-up comedy and i think like
people's careers have their ups and
downs i think stand-up comedy has its
ups and downs and i think it's on an
upswing now
it just happened to premiere the same
weekend at the david tells comedy
underground premiere which was great i
loved the way i mean he had those shows
that were shot with gopros the audience
holding gopros i thought boy how you
talking about reinventing the wheel and
reshooting the show i mean that was a
show you watched and you felt like you
were in the audience and
david tell did one of the funniest dudes
out there working i mean just he just
kind of reinvented the wheel and he took
charge of it and he ended all those
episodes he said i was going to let
comedy central they they look at comedy
the way romanian orphanages looking
children
[ __ ] comedy essential things just
right yeah but he he oversaw the editing
and say hey i just got done and it
looked great man i mean yeah and he did
the thing is i was talking to somebody
else from uh that had something going on
with comedy central they said that
when the whole experience was over they
were in shock how much they didn't know
how much they ended up doing themselves
if not nobody else would do it and i
explained to them i said
there's so many people in this town that
think that they depend so much on their
managers and their agents
and i was raised a different way than
you have one shot i give you in the old
days i used to give you one shot
go call warner brothers find out what's
going on in that role i'll call you in a
half hour what's going on well i called
and left the message you're done
you're done that's it message
message you're done
you know before the computer thing came
there was a time i had three agents once
once gatlin left no i know you were
working i was working i had three agents
on paper
that did not know about each other and i
would see and it taught me something as
i was scamming it also taught me how
they saw me
so i would see how this guy would call
me with a distinct different look and i
knew that this guy and this guy had seen
the same breakdown
yeah but this guy saw something
different then and i learned how
different agents saw me yeah and that
was very interesting but there's a guy i
bumped into i swear to god at
at uh
at uh
marie et about a month ago
his name was greg mayo great guy
the guy had been here
30 years
greg mayo just greg mayo yeah he had an
office inventory he was a one-man show
he started at icm in the 70s
and like in 87 he says i'm done with icm
and all these big agents
i'm going to take 40 people i'm going to
book theater and character actors
i happen to bump into the guy at a gay
gym christy miller
oh yeah gave me a free pass to gold when
she was a manager at the gold in in
gower right nick oh yeah
that's the gay uh
nice people well no no he started
talking to me i could tell he wasn't
trying to hit on me he just asked me
who's your agent you have a nice look to
you
and right away i was a little
apprehensive and i met him up in his
office and the guy turned out to be a
great agent i'll tell you how great of
an agent he was
he took a sam weissman sam weissman was
a big time comedy director and we got
he's done that but he directed the david
spade films
he saw a part for an extra
in that movie he contacted the [ __ ]
guy and he goes wouldn't it be funny
if joey diaz walked in there with a
[ __ ] and five black guys he sold it
guys this is what i'm talking about yeah
he sold it but he was gay and he used to
go to palm springs
yeah and
in my world there's no vacations no not
you know what i'm saying like he would
leave on friday not come back till
tuesday do it down there all week and do
deep deep over fire
and eating [ __ ] ramen and whatever
the [ __ ]
they eat right
and he's down there jumping up and down
and i called him
hey [ __ ]
i [ __ ] call him one day
on like a tuesday and i go out there
jumping up and down this is one third
this isn't ramen
i think i'm [ __ ] kidding you guys
this is when the longest yard breakdown
came out and and one of the agents i had
called me goes hey man the longest yard
came i go call him back
and he called him back and he he was the
first person that goes he goes i don't
think so they're not going to see you
because they were looking for a star
they either want tony ceragusa a big
[ __ ] from the sopranos
and i was like that's not good enough
and i asked the gay agent greg mayo yeah
a great male call gun and then i had
somebody else
i had somebody i had greg at acme he was
just a pilot i just sold him weed and he
made certain calls for me he was one of
those dudes that all he did was set up
casting director workshops and different
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of 18 year olds yeah
when i'd see him on tuesday he'd have
[ __ ] cam this is before the phone and
the camera this guy actually went in
with cameras took pictures and took him
back to his hotel and said get naked
suck my dick i'll get you a job who was
the [ __ ] guy from colonel hogan what
was the dude's name from hogan's heroes
bob crane he had the [ __ ] bob crane
started the bob crane started this guy
was getting his dick sucked all over the
country on casting director workshop so
you [ __ ] people see those castles
like the workshops mind your business
don't go to them they put like 200 bucks
and they have to read yeah they tell you
have a career in this [ __ ] yeah and
meanwhile you got nothing you gotta got
you like pinocchio and a geico
commercial the guy says to you you have
a future and his nose grows
[ __ ] so guys like a pedophile with a
[ __ ] one of those honey boo boo can
[ __ ] great
shows greg was worthless unless i got
him a coke rock
or like eight ounces of weed which i
pinched an ounce and put water in the
bag oh i used to work this guy i used to
sell him the wettest weed in town he
always tell me how come this weed's
drink
because i gotta make a living cuz i
would spray it with a spray bottle to
make it weigh
and he put in the trunk of the car and
it would dry and he'd lose an ounce
automatically who do you think you're
dealing that's an old [ __ ] street
thing
so okay come on lee you want to run with
juice lee or you want to run with that
i'm pretty impressed that's a pretty
good jeez that's nothing that's back in
the day that's bad
back in the day you will buy an eighth
for [ __ ] 200 you go upstairs do one
throw three and a half grams of cut on
it run it out get your original eighth
back
welcome padre
it's three and a half i took like two
grams out and drew like aspirin in it
and he kept calling me and i wouldn't
take his call he forgot all about he
never said none of me paul rodriguez
gave me 250 one i caught a medic i
caught paul at el compadre
this is after i got rid of me paul right
in front of the [ __ ] house
[ __ ] gardener right there right there
i knew paul was a [ __ ] dirty coke fan
and one night but welcome padre after
latino and he goes can you get something
up here i go absolutely i go what do you
want he goes honey ball go give me 300 i
bought the a ball and left
never gave it to him that [ __ ]
never said a word to me
why did he bargain for it like why
didn't he figure out how much money you
wanted i didn't give a [ __ ] yeah he
didn't remember bro you don't remember i
told him give me 300 for the eight ball
he probably bought three eight balls on
his own while he was there forgot about
it oh yeah [ __ ] craziness lee [ __ ]
craziness
but but we know the three agents so
what happened was the longer shot came
out i go greg had juice i go great call
john
the guy on venice boulevard cool casting
cat
john something i go call him up and get
me in there
and he calls me right back there's cow
cow i don't know if i could get you in
there that's a strong office that night
jim kellem comes to see me
at the ice house you have an agent
i got like three of them but i could use
a fourth
i don't know if you can kill them i go
okay yeah the office is up there right
above subway over there by the wig shop
can you get me can you get me into the
longest shot he goes what john pap
sadera who's a cool [ __ ] he cast
me in three or four things let me tell
you how much juice he's got i went to
vegas one day i was nines and that
[ __ ] was sitting there with tony
bennett just him and tony bennett that's
then i went to the [ __ ] motorcycle
convention in milwaukee who's at my
hotel john [ __ ] whatever his name
that's how bad that casting guy is
he's also casting that show now in
showtime
what's the show with all the stars on it
with [ __ ] the dude and he plays the
hollywood fixer with stephen donovan
right
have you seen that show have you seen
anything a couple of times yeah it's
okay
don't do nothing it ain't on tournaments
ain't the sopranos yeah so uh
don't don't
hold your hats when you negotiate with
these desert people
so uh
so i talked to calum and kellen's like i
get you the movie part whatever
well sure enough they call you know they
called to offer my movie to who out of
all the agents i had calling there and
all the people guess who they call to go
off of the movie to stacy pocalude
that's how stupid warner brothers was
she's a publicist and somehow i know
they got stacey's name and they're like
stacy i would like to offer joey d as a
role in the long as you understand like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
stacy call me and she goes they're
looking for you they want to cash it
so i called jim kellem and i called
the gay guy
to see who would hit the mark first
kellum got it first he got the
commission i went i went up there i
fired the gay guy
fired him that afternoon i gotta go i
got a big agent i left him two weeks
later he's looking at variety and i get
cast of the longest yard he's fuming
he's calling everybody
really yeah and he called me and i told
him the truth and said doug i had to let
you go because
you told me they were looking for a star
so you're done i am a [ __ ] star
how you gonna tell me you're looking for
a star
i put the [ __ ] thing down i sent the
tape myself now everybody wants a piece
of the action nobody's getting nothing
in my world it's first man who dials
its first man who dials we and him are
going to do something i called this
production lady on a monday at 10
o'clock she didn't answer the phone i
ain't doing business with you
i call you on a monday at 10 o'clock you
don't answer the phone i ain't doing
business with you
how the [ __ ] you're not gonna answer the
phone like monday and then you call me
back like at 3 30.
what you want nothing
nothing really i don't deal with people
monday you got to answer the phone eight
eight o'clock if you got to be there at
nine
i call you at 8 30 just to see what type
of heart you got if you answered hello
bro you did yeah listen i need this and
this and this thing let's get this going
yeah that's the best time to call
actually yeah i don't [ __ ] around ain't
got nothing going on just got there yeah
give them something to do yeah come on
now why would you want to do business
with somebody who doesn't answer the
[ __ ] phone one day at eight o'clock
in the morning i want your attention
monday to the clock
you you do call me eight o'clock almost
every morning eight o'clock there you go
i got no time to [ __ ] around
actually six years old you don't drink
you don't do blow and you know what that
would you be happy too because you were
playing games i ain't got time for that
[ __ ] you stay up to three [ __ ] around
i'm gonna call you at eight that's five
hours when i was 26 i slept one hour
with an eye open
the [ __ ] that's called a hollywood
wake-up call let's call it hollywood
that's true if you're young today i was
watching uh a boiler room was on
and it was the beginning when uh
the guy from boston is giving the speech
in the office
and he said something that's true he
goes give me he walks in and he tried to
pull up what's his name alex baldwin got
the best speech ever
gary
but the second one is this kid this kid
walks and he goes hi
get the [ __ ] up you sit in my chair get
up get out that's how it opens up to me
and then the other kid who's gonna
seriously save his license i do get the
[ __ ] out i don't we don't hire brokers
we train him here and he goes listen i'm
gonna keep this nice and simple
you're gonna be a millionaire in three
years
okay
now in the process
i don't give a [ __ ] about your mother
i'm gonna talk about your family i
really don't i'm telling you you're
gonna be a millionaire in three [ __ ]
years you're 21.
you could [ __ ] around at 21.
or
you could [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out you
want to take vacations go teach school
you want to take vacations go teach
school we don't take vacations here
don't ask we work 24 7 sundays and
saturdays double
so you're not gonna do that get the [ __ ]
out but you're gonna be a millionaire in
three years
because and or not you'll be a
millionaire five years because with that
work ethic at 20. yeah they can't stop
you and that's what most
kids today do not have it's a joke it's
twitter it's facebook it's [ __ ]
uh the [ __ ] games with the whatever
guys are having too many distractions
yeah people are trying to write the
great american tweet
yeah and there's too many [ __ ]
distractions people trying to shoot a
[ __ ] you know
and it's true at 21 you should want to
[ __ ]
make 10 million dollars yeah i don't
understand
when i was 21 i was either gonna steal
it
or make it i didn't know how i was gonna
do it but in the meantime i ain't going
to miss a meal if it's between me
missing a meal or that wallet falling
out of your pocket guess what i got a
magnet in my hand you got a magnet in
your [ __ ] pocket
you know i didn't know what you know i
don't understand the mentality but
people come to you and that's how we've
discussed this a million times everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die
you know how many comics you talk to
they'll call you up and say judy well
jimmy it's just not happening for me man
well do me a favor go down to the improv
this week i can't i'm going to play golf
yeah
i can't talk to you you know what's
funny man i can't talk yeah i play golf
but i play golf when i'm [ __ ] doing
sarasota i'm out i'm not on the road i'm
not going to miss an audition i'm out
there yeah i'll play i'll play a little
round of golf you know
not even golf they tell you they're
going to their father their sister's
wedding yeah give a [ __ ] about your
[ __ ] sister you put 200 involved
today i got an invite to my niece's
wedding i love her she's one of my
favorite knees but guess what she's got
a deuce in the envelope yeah i'm in
minneapolis and cancer minneapolis
october 16th
a little [ __ ] wedding first of all
that's college football season so that
dude's a [ __ ] you married the wrong
[ __ ] dude nobody gets married on
college saturday
that's a big [ __ ] mistake
you don't you don't we've had this
[ __ ] discussion you got to look at
the calendar and say if and look at
everybody's calendar yes everybody's
counting who doesn't get married april
may june may june july it's boring
there's no football there's no conflicts
you miss a baseball game there's another
one tomorrow you know what i'm saying
but college
come on you're not gonna [ __ ] and i
don't even like college football i'm
telling you i wouldn't [ __ ] go just
out of principle
that's how i [ __ ] roll [ __ ]
where's tony better that
you're slipping today you're over there
sitting half marked up
it's a beautiful day to be alive
[ __ ] monday
march 9th
little church
you're
it was better than this
i'm getting hit right now with those
mushrooms that's what's better than this
those mushrooms are creeping while i'm
sleeping me too and oh [ __ ] the thc
stuff thank god i got a cookie first
lethal either oh no like put the music
on who told the [ __ ]
what do you dj turn it off put the
[ __ ] music
no but sometimes like if i got drunk and
then i tried to get high it wouldn't
happen
and last time we did the mushrooms we
did the mushrooms first and i couldn't
feel the star
but we did the star first today and now
the mushrooms are they're both kicking
i'm just three pharmacists though i know
how to mix and match and keep you alive
i gotta piss we gotta we gotta there's
no pissing during the show no no come on
i gotta [ __ ] my backpack
there's no pissing during the [ __ ]
show [ __ ]
oh my god i'm loving it today
what's the story
can't turn the music off no you can't
turn the [ __ ] music on what's going
on you got sciatica no my dad does oh i
did he's doing good
you know i don't [ __ ] around that's why
i got this head dude
so what else
i did a podcast last night like one in
the morning
i was just i was super bored because of
the time change
what happened
um so i just i had a a melted
green hornet in my drawer that you would
get mad at me for not eating so i pulled
it out
and i started talking to people on
twitter and we did like a 45 minute
podcast good for you brother see you had
a good time nobody got their feelings
here you're looking good what are you
losing down you're down in 90. no still
85.
but like i'm finally getting to the
point where there's like i'm back to the
lowest what are you eating what are you
eating over the weekend that you're not
losing the weight with mama it wasn't
that it was
like my trip to florida then there was
valentine's day it seemed like there was
like from since november
it's been um
just like there's one excuse after
another to cheat
and it it's so and like i'm it's my
fault but
since then i've been kind of just i i
haven't gained which is cool but other
than that i've been kind of staying
mama's diet she's doing great she's
almost at 80 pounds really yeah she's
beating and [ __ ] no i'm beating her
still barely but i had more to lose she
didn't [ __ ] you up pretty soon she's
gonna just pass right by you see
she'd go you could give her that's how
you [ __ ] her up you gotta give her a
star and watch you eat ice cream then
you could be there that's how you have
to do it you have to be on top of the
[ __ ] thing you have american
ingenuity what i'm saying
she's applying to be like a district
attorney i don't think she wants to have
she don't never know please don't listen
she takes the piss test that's like two
years from now
that she could do heroin every night
this year and still come back clean all
right so don't worry about it close that
door jimmy douches before the cops bust
in here and think that we got mushrooms
and [ __ ]
it's uh
it's [ __ ] up that kennison's been gone
so long i read the i reread the book the
other day did you really i mean it's
been 23 years bro 23 yeah 21 no
uh
93
92 92 20 92 dude that's i think about it
all the time i think about uh
god that seems like a lifetime ago but
boy was that fun
you know
and you know the funny thing is i i
think back on his legacy you know and
you go you know like bill hicks is a guy
who has become more famous posture
misleading and sam sam's kind of he was
you know dropped down a little bit i
don't think he left the you know i mean
he's a great comedian an amazing
comedian but didn't i don't think left
in the big enough body work you know
it's just 23 years
23 years ago this this april it will be
23 years
march 10th
it's amazing that uh seven o'clock
yeah i still remember
you know going home and not being
surprised like going you know like not
going wow like
well you know the thing is i'm just glad
because having toured with him and hung
out with him and there's a friend of his
i i was glad that he didn't know dee
in a hotel room like [ __ ] blue she
would like [ __ ] two hookers and stuff
like that i mean there's the guy you
know was protecting his wife and some
guy was in a head-on collision the other
guy was at fault he was protecting his
wife he lost his life but his wife lived
uh they lost the child she was pregnant
at the time so you think about that and
you go man that's just
he just kind of rolls out of the car and
the beau was there and just you know he
goes i don't want to go because don't
worry you're not going to die and he
realizes he's not talking to him he's
looking past him i mean just carl's
there holding these cars are driving
over these beer cans we're in the back
of the pickup truck they're now on the
road and they're spraying all over the
back of his head and he goes i have
those [ __ ] memories like that the
beard just spraying on my head and he
just realized he goes he just
he just expired
in his arms you know and it was like you
know those guys had a
you know
uh a friendship that started was start
they were both there they started the
same night and then they kind of ended
you know i mean carla beau i [ __ ]
love the death but the guys you know
got the shitty into the stick in that
deal you know there's a but but still
one of the funniest dudes working on one
of the most physical comics out there
i've ever known you know it's just it's
just it was a crazy time you know i i
think i was just young enough at the
time to survive it all i mean there's
deuters i mean i knock wood every day
going man i there's a freaking 100
nights you could odd or whatever you're
hanging with these guys i mean you're
touring with this dude is one of those
controversial comedians in america at
the time doing
you know [ __ ] 3 500 people and doing
the spectrum in philadelphia where i
used to go out you know the flyers and
the sixers playing you're doing 6 300
people and your entire family's in the
audience and that day there was a
[ __ ] story in the newspaper there was
an interview with you and you had these
[ __ ] great cool moments you know so
yeah
and i want and not to mention the guy
was a [ __ ] brilliant comedian i mean
people if you go back and you watch your
stuff it still stands up
it's still impressive [ __ ] i mean you
know it's and that whole you know hicks
and him it kind of started together so
it was like i think maybe he took a
beyond
but even if you listen to hicks hicks's
stuff i mean letterman did we ran a
hicks set
on the anniversary that his mom won
which i thought was really cool i don't
know why we beat this guy because i
thought it was great there was nothing
in there we could and he apologized to
his mom that it was but you know that
that was that you know there's
you know if you read i just finished
reading a great book called comedy from
the edge by richard zaglin have you read
that book about but he just talks about
how stand-up comedy in 1970s changed
america
and he literally takes it from you know
lenny to carlin and pryor who became
counter culture got cons who influenced
this whole generation who influenced
that whole generation and influenced
that generation and just how i mean
because you think about it wasn't even
like a real occupation at the time i
mean there was guys doing vaudeville and
then there was a guy's doing nightclubs
and then [ __ ] 1980s you had the
explosion of all these comedy clubs you
could actually [ __ ] making a living
doing stand-up comedy before i don't
think you could
but it's it's it's a great read
but uh yeah you think i think about
those guys like you know if i can do
richard jenny was one of those guys who
would watch without just [ __ ] pound
for pounds one of the funniest dudes i
mean as far as structurally joke
structure and just [ __ ] boom i mean
you know you kind of miss that a little
bit
you know i mean guys who do it well i
mean dude i i don't know maybe i told
you this before but it's like
i started i was doing a festival in
ireland my [ __ ] mom and dad came over
to ireland my brothers my old man got to
see me perform in ireland you know cross
that off the [ __ ] bucket list and
coming back i'm sitting with [ __ ] dom
and he goes i'm so glad your family came
over he goes i don't he goes i don't
know
he goes i would never be doing a show in
italy i can invite my family so i was
hoping that you would bring your family
and everybody came out they had dinner
that night and dom on the way back we're
waiting for the plane and he says i
wonder if you're uh
because i wonder if your family realized
how tough it was for you to do and i
said what do you mean
he's with jimmy if i can play in the a
comedy club you're playing all the clubs
that you see everybody in he goes yeah
he goes how many [ __ ] guys you know
to do that i said
no guys i'm serious how many guys you
know that are alive that are doing it
they're doing a high level i said [ __ ] i
could probably come up with 80 90 names
you go yeah together we probably have
crossover but i bet you would come up
130 names okay yeah
he goes you know how many professional
baseball players you know
i said you know 20
25 man rushers 32 teams it's like 750
guys yeah give or take you know nhl is a
little less nba's a little less because
there's still a pretty [ __ ] elite
group because it's a really you're
making you're living as a professional
stand-up comedian i had never thought
about it in those [ __ ] terms before i
had never never even in my mind and went
wow yeah if you think about it you're
making your living doing stand-up comedy
that's i mean and if you're doing it at
a [ __ ] high level and you're doing
all those clubs that's [ __ ] dude it's
an elite group i i didn't i didn't put
that much thought into it but it really
kind of woke me up a little bit was a i
thought it was a great observation
i feel right now at times i'm living in
a dream
i am working at places that 10 years ago
i never dreamed of even contacting yeah
i never dreamed of even walking into i'm
talking to people that i never thought
i heard about them and i never thought i
would have have the opportunity to meet
those people yeah every time i wake up
i'm so [ __ ] thankful well you put the
work in joey you put the work in i mean
it's like it's like just perseverance i
mean you've hung in there and
opportunities he presented himself and i
think you've taken really
uh
uh taken those opportunities and taken
them to the freaking end but never
thought of it like this i never thought
i'd be capable
to put
that people would come see me i never
thought of it in that term i always
thought of it as yeah i'll do comedy
no but dude you're a [ __ ] genuine
what's going on with you over there
everything's like sucker you're
breathing
like you're dying over there get it
together
it's cool like the past few weeks you've
gone to a few places where
you were excited but before you like i
don't know how i'm gonna do here and
then i call you thursday night and you
have like 200 seats sold yeah it's
pretty crazy and the people that are
coming out the people that are coming
out i'm talking to them after shows and
i'm taking pictures and i'm feeling them
i'm feeling what they're saying i can't
[ __ ] believe it let me tell you i
live in a dream like i live in a dream
every day i go this is gonna pop it's
yeah i know exactly because i'm going
through it right now just because the
last comic standard you're doing a thing
now in the last couple times i've had
probably like the last six weeks on
saturday night sold out shows hit
bonuses [ __ ] people come up and just
hanging out taking pictures and meeting
your people but you know the thing is
guys like larry the cable guy i don't
even care what you think about but i
know the dude's working i knew him
before larry cable guy and dan whitney
is one of those guys stand there and
shake every hand talk to people that's
how you build your fan base i mean i
never understand a guy who doesn't come
out and meet these [ __ ] people the
kid just paid [ __ ] 25 bucks to come
see him go out and hang out shake their
hand and freaking drink with them i mean
you know we it's weird but i'll tell you
it's it's been happening i'm going
through the same thing now but it's
awesome i mean you go you know you know
how hard and how long you work to get
there you did not take that for granted
oh it's very special yeah
it's something that uh
i'm grateful when i see people who
aren't grateful and act like jerk offs
and i hear stories about them on st i
get [ __ ] pissed it makes me because
we're so fortunate we fly every week i
know people who don't [ __ ] fly at all
who if you're telling me they're gonna
get on a plane
they think like it's [ __ ] great i
take flying for granted i know the
airports i know the food at different
airports yeah i get excited if i'm
flying out of newark i always try to get
those crab cakes out of united the best
in the country five places to the top
five oh yeah you get two crab cakes with
two [ __ ] eggs sunny side up two
pieces of wheat toast
before you get on that 5 a.m flight push
you right into nappy new newville by the
time you get the [ __ ] la it's 9
o'clock
dude i was just in asia check this out i
think that's [ __ ] crap dude i'm just
an age i was if i flew to hong kong had
a nightmare you did the same rooms
already did yeah i i'm the one who got
ari in there carrie said hey i want to
go over here and check it out i miss
bill burb i do that bill burrows over in
uh freaking singapore and hong kong i'm
in shanghai i'm just crossing over him
he went to mumbai after that he did like
a tour right through there but i mean
you go out there and there's these
expats these americans australians
english english-speaking audiences that
just love american stand-up comedy and
they bring you over you get to stay in
i'm telling you the the best hotels i've
ever been in the hospitality's first
class they take care of you man you've
got enough dea you want to go out and
get everybody taken care of you don't
have to speak the language although it's
nice to know a few long few lines like
nietzsche
how much for a hand job
no that's just just not the way to get
yourself around a massage joint no i'm
just kidding but it's uh but it's cool
man the food is [ __ ] amazing it's
just experience going on i get to go
people save up their whole lives for a
trip just to go to beijing where the air
quality is so ridiculously bad but i've
been there and went to the forbidden
city don't ever go there and i know why
it's forbidden they didn't have a
starbucks in there but i'm just saying
why would you go dude you don't realize
how many asian people are dude it's 1.7
it's a 1.7 billion i mean the 0.7 is
more than we have in our entire country
it's like freaking
it's like uh
for every chinese guy there's nine
chinese guys
it's it's ridiculous but but it's cool i
mean i get to have that trip and i've
done it a couple times now but
yeah you go [ __ ] man this is what's
better than this
you know
i've been going to israel i went to
israel dude we did some shows for the
kobe mandel foundation i mean
yeah i got to travel every week anyway
but i mean those trips are just for me i
want to go see some [ __ ] you know
yeah and it's uh
it's hard to describe me in 1994 in a
one-bedroom rocky apartment
that's what my friends used to call my
apartment
rocky park i lived in north boulder i
paid 400 a month there was a little
kitchen when you walked in that i never
lit the [ __ ] stove one time in three
years
not once the refrigerator never had a
stitch of food in it just fat tie a beer
and water for the next morning recovery
and a little gatorade from time to time
the gas station was down the corner i
had no phone
no phone ever in that place you want to
call them we got to call the gas station
all right
this is no [ __ ] that's what you could
live off the ground how would you find
out you got a call i didn't care
i didn't care
they would take messages at the gas
station and i would pay you back from
the pay phone with a calling card
this is how [ __ ] up my life was well
if i wanted to call you if you lived
around the corner i had to walk to the
gas station to call you it was [ __ ]
people would pick me up at the gas
station i would tell people pick me up
at the gas i lived across from north
boulder recreation center yeah bro that
[ __ ] builds character by the way you
walked in i had a little tub shower
stand-up shower with a sliding door
a toilet and there was a wall that had a
little hole in it and i used to throw my
empty bindles in there one night after
the swan i left coconut bin like i
ripped the wall down and there was a
million [ __ ] binders behind there and
now one of them with coke all of them
had molding them from me licking them
and closing them everyone had green in
them i had to put the wall back up the
landlord kept coming down to sit and i'd
go you can't go in the bathroom why not
cause i i wouldn't let them in because i
ripped the wall down it was [ __ ] my
bedroom was beautiful i had a beautiful
window beautiful bedroom
but it was connected the bed the bed i
had took everything up
so basically the door didn't open and
shut you just fell in
i haven't i've had that room before i
didn't have a bureau before
this was the apartment and it was clean
no mice beautiful it was just a rocky
apartment i had a bench
yeah for a dining room table that's all
you needed i had a sony trinitron from
the old days and i was getting them
shipped out you know i kept one and i
had a [ __ ] couch from medieval times
that somebody left on the
porch and i doped it up puerto rican it
up steam cleaned it upstairs and it was
brand new for the sitting and you would
sit there and just sleep on your psyche
you know if they could just walk one
shot and they realized that it wasn't
the hammer [ __ ] the guy from the
neighborhood made it good you know oh my
god i used to go there and get poked up
they had a little window in the middle
living room i used to hide from that
little window so i turned the light in
the bathroom off and just hiding the
[ __ ] matches it was just horrid but i
loved the place it was clean but i used
to go back there at night after i'd do
comedy
and i would read just for laughs
remember the newspaper that john fox
used to put up in san francisco yeah
yeah and in the back there was a comedy
club guide
and i would circle the clubs i was going
to perform at eggbees and the comedy
store yeah
and just the houston laptop because that
was all that 91 93 i was just in your
old stomach rounds i was up there in
tacoma i was up there doing that uh the
tacoma comedy club so what's in tacoma
it's a great club it's a family-run
operation but i'm telling you it used to
be the underground they bought it no no
no no this is a brand new room this is a
great room this is a blue collar
audience that comes in there they're a
freaking man i was just in tacoma dude
i'm telling you the coma comedy club for
my money i mean they got that you know
they got those high-end places up in
bellevue and you know in seattle in the
the room development the the parlor
that's what you can get apart it was
nice i've done those rooms but i'm
telling you man i tap into that audience
in tacoma working class blue collar
people want to come there they want to
they want to laugh
and you come out and you come out of
that swing and bing bing punchline dick
joke they're on board everybody's going
to i mean it was great so you're working
every week now yeah oh yeah man yeah i
mean not you know i you know i try to
hang out i try to you know audition when
i'm in town but you know i'm not i'm
still running running that high from
last comic i have not stopped [ __ ]
working since thinking about that show
which is the great thing believe me and
it's great
and i'm working on a new hour for
netflix i'm developing that and putting
that together we're taping that like the
third week in august putting all that
stuff together i'm coming out with a
brand new brand new [ __ ] hour and
then that's what i've been working on
jimmy schubert where's the crazy
ex-girlfriend the white one that lived
in florida that was a bro sign with
three yards before she left
where is she ah she's she's in st
augustine with her parents you know her
parents are getting older dad just went
with him some stuff so she kind of moved
back to be with her parents and
you know i i guess i i guess she's happy
i don't really kind of you know get
involved i mean there's a reason they're
an ex-girlfriend you know i'm saying bro
you guys was the last time you spoke to
me you call it once a year you talked to
them maybe yeah you know but maybe a
couple of years ago i just i've kind of
moved on you know i moved honest like
you know and i really didn't listen i'm
surprised you even talked to it three
years ago yeah i'm just asking maybe to
you saw her on a picture on her face
for seven years man she was [ __ ] nuts
we all we've all had a girlfriend that
dude who was just nuts and i remember
seeing her like at eight o'clock at
night in miami and then bumping into at
five yeah and going like what the [ __ ]
you were going home at 8 30. you did a
spot yeah
women are the only people that they
could tell you something and then 10
minutes later there's something called
you could call a woman and go what's up
what are you doing i'm staying and i'll
see you when you get here when you get
there's a note
susie came over she fell down the stairs
she needed somebody to have a drink with
what are you talking about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
susie fell i don't give a [ __ ] about
this yeah dude you're wearing aspirin at
home
let me tell you something i love that
girl but she was a [ __ ] handful she
was like kim bassinger from blind nate
whatever you do don't give her any
liquor bro don't do any shots with her
because i'm telling and look i mean dude
i probably stayed in that relationship a
couple years longer than i should have
but i mean you know she was uh
you know that's where you that's where
you learn those lessons you go be
careful the people you let into your
life because it says a lot about who the
[ __ ] you are the dog i had the stripper
for four years
which was a [ __ ] nightmare yeah and
she still calls me she called me the
other day to tell him to talk to me
about something
investing opportunities or jiu jitsu
opening up a jiu jitsu school she like
and it's always every boyfriend of hers
ends up in jail
i have not even this white guy now her
fiance ended up in jail what happened he
was on probation and he what what what's
the common denominator now what's the
commodity she's [ __ ] crazy yeah the
common denominator is her yeah she's so
poisoned that even as a boyfriend you
pay for her sins
even as a boyfriend
you pay for her sins and i had a lot of
fun with a lot of laughs
you know yeah it was it was it was
taxing on your soul and people always
ask me man there was a point i know
you're joey i'm in la you were having a
hard time you really weren't that funny
i don't know how you were getting by
then one day you just got funny the day
i stopped dating that girl well my life
changed forever it was four years of
you know sixty percent of your time is
thinking about this person like what
is going on there's no you know what it
is you you can't even think about or
create possibilities in your own world
because it was it was too much it's so
you know it's rich and the [ __ ] and all
the sex was great she let me [ __ ]
torture her and tie her up and stab her
i mean she let me [ __ ] her in the ass
but at the end of the day it wasn't
worth it i'd rather just get a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] you once a month and have no
drama
she was a filthy [ __ ] animal she was
getting the ex-boyfriend mass while you
[ __ ] her
up i had to beat the boyfriend up the x
he came out i got arrested it was
four years i ended up fighting with her
on on in front of gavin's house
she was going to hit me with a stake and
i was no i was going to hit her with a
[ __ ] meat loaf and she was going to
hit me with mace
and i threw a change
remember walking away from it going this
is
is this even [ __ ] dude
dude i got news for you i will [ __ ]
never do that never now once you do it
one time you'll go yeah wow no it's easy
to say oh my god but i never never did i
deal with anything
you know i was never a sex addict
i like my dick suck i like smoking coke
that's when i get those dirty thoughts
beside that i don't get dirty thoughts i
don't need to get [ __ ] every night when
i was first doing comedy i had that
rocky apartment i was in that rocky
apartment for four years i think two
girls walked in the door because i
always had something after like 27 i had
this saying that a buddy of mine told me
before you bring him home ask yourself
if you want to wake up to this [ __ ]
animal
once the booze is done and it's like
that old saying look at a guy and put a
police suit on him if it fits don't [ __ ]
with him he's a cop yeah i used to for
years when i was 27 i learned a very
valuable lesson if you look at a woman
you could tell this [ __ ] is going to be
a pain in the ass in the morning
you want to wake up to this [ __ ] i
don't care how good the blow job is i
don't care she's going to stick a tongue
up my ass first i only got a gram
and i'm not going to take a chance with
this animal if i bring her home and she
don't suck my dick i'm gonna kill her
because i only got a gram i got three
quarters of a [ __ ] gram she better
suck my dick
so
if i'm thinking this i just say forget
it i don't know
he's got a rough [ __ ] brother go rub
one out do a tissue in love roll over a
call no no no no you wake up the bar is
a brand new oh my god there was a point
in my life i didn't want women around i
didn't want nobody around
but the only way you would come over if
i knew you were a sure thing like i
don't want to talk about it as a matter
of fact as soon as you walk in just drop
your dress
because i don't want to talk about this
later let's smart some coke let me suck
your titties just together out of the
way let me suck your [ __ ] just to go
and women will look at me and go you
crazy yeah yeah yeah let's do a couple
lines listen there's no reason to do
that yeah yeah yeah yeah there's no
reason there's no reason to do no lines
i'll give you one line let me yes and
let's get it out of the way so the rest
of the night we could just rest and just
relax
you have this sexual tension all night
back and forth and then i gotta wait for
you to let the pit fall out my mistake i
don't have that you know what every
broad does that the shirt rolls off the
shoulder the titty pops out and then
they start and then you say pop it out i
don't have time for that either let's
right off the bat take off your pants
what are you talking about take over
suck my dick let me eat your [ __ ] if
now i don't know you're real i don't
know you're [ __ ] real it's like when
you sell coke to somebody they just
leave like miami vice they buy a kilo
and just leave you know what before you
take this kill let me see you do [ __ ]
for [ __ ] horse blast
not like neil simon in that movie what's
up now i'm talking to the king where you
need a [ __ ] garden hose to get the
only way i'm doing this
and you people think i'm [ __ ] nuts no
i'm not nuts when i only got 60 and a
half a gram of blow i ain't taking a
chance it's like people go well i heard
that this place is a great restaurant no
no no no hoy's walk is known and proven
we ain't taking a chance with your [ __ ]
little hindu restaurant because they got
no we're going to go to [ __ ] hoy's
walk where it's 495 i got a soup i got
an egg roll i got a [ __ ] cheap
[ __ ] fried snack i got a non-crag at
white bread and if you're lucky the lady
gives you a little [ __ ] fortune
cookie for 490 [ __ ] five i'm gonna
take a chance and go to this place cause
you like it or your friends [ __ ] you and
your [ __ ] friend we're going to this
[ __ ] lunch spot and that's how it
works out that's it yeah you don't want
to walk there's a restaurant there's a
lot of people yeah hey it must be good
no because how many that's the law
listen
we are [ __ ] saps as humanity how do
you know if a team is going to lose ask
10 people
go up to 10 people
we've discussed this before jimmy
schumer yeah you know
it's hysterical and i used to work for
the sports betting service which i
watched that movie for a little while
yesterday two for the money with al
pacino and yeah yeah matthew mcconaughey
now the company i work for i work for
colorado sports advisors but their main
parent company
was sports advisor something and it was
mike duffy and
and this other [ __ ] uh jewish guy who
thought he was in the mafia he
threatened me one time i told him to
suck my dick finer
so one of those guys left and stole the
idea and made a script and sold it and
these guys tried to sell them they
couldn't sell that's the only thing the
problem with that movie was they
couldn't sell it they got too many good
looking guys good looking guys don't do
that business it's people who look evil
but when i work through those what's the
point of [ __ ] the story i don't know
but all i remember is i made a [ __ ]
big bowl of this [ __ ] chili you came
over to watch monday night [ __ ] when
we watch the broncos and i'm laying you
watching you calling the game three
plays [ __ ] out you were telling me
about barking about you go this
[ __ ] he goes here's how hallway
is you called this two players like yo
this guy's running in he runs and he
gets pounded but he gets it in the
freaking end zone you go he's calling
his own number i mean he was three plays
ahead
i'm telling you that's how sharp i used
to be with sports betty that's the truth
like i could that's a good story to tell
you this was at his old [ __ ] house
spaghetti meatballs followed by many
other things and hiding in closet
me being late for basketball
that's why i lived in studio city i
lived right down the corner here with
the stripper yeah and i was shooting
basketball and i was coked up and we
drank red wine
and then we got there six in the morning
and they're like today you shoot you're
the second scene up and every dad would
just go in there and sleep
this is the day i came in gacked up to
the gills that i had to [ __ ] shoot
basketball
i didn't know my lines i they kept
saying step on your mark
i didn't know what a mark was
i didn't know what cut was
nothing when they called me and they
said how do you want your name in the
cut at the end of the movie and i go
i made the movie and they're like yeah
you were great i'm like
i was pale
somebody put the picture up today i know
you look really young yeah really
yeah i remember that night bro oh please
[ __ ] i've done it yeah but and what i
was trying to say is at the end of your
pitch to people once i called jimmy
schumer and i go jimmy schubert pete
patel colorado sports advisors listen
we've discussed this before
i'm going two for two tonight i got the
game in the total you're a nickel better
you're gonna walk away with 25 [ __ ]
hundred do me a favor grab the credit
card what's the number we're running out
of time jimmy at the end after i give
you a mental ear beat and if you make it
all the way to the end i always say to
you who are you betting
just for curiosity right what do you got
tonight they'd say stealers in the oven
no matter what they tell you you always
said listen
you're on the other side
one of your bets is wrong
and nine out of ten thank you for that
they would tell me
if eight out of ten people gave me miami
it was the other team that won
we're [ __ ] morons as as a as a a
group yeah that's why i love when people
tell me they went four and oh and they
did
because you can't every week you have to
be in a season you're gonna get six good
picks
you're just not gonna know when to lay
ten thousand on them that's the magic
yeah that's the secret that's the guy
who makes when you hit it when you hit
it you go any [ __ ] [ __ ] could pick
go six for right in the football season
bet 20 times in the game
and you're still up
130 for the year
right now
dude i know what you're saying you
understand me so for you to bet every
game that that's how you gamble you
gamble like a snake you only [ __ ]
come up
and you come right back and you take
your ten thousand and you go home and
then they're waiting for your call next
week but you ain't gambling you ain't
that stupid you're gonna wait for that
feeling yeah then you come again that's
the real [ __ ] gambler but at the end
of the conversation i would always go
and the next day you would always lose
at least one if you lost two i can't
tell you i had a blackjack dealer in
reno and i've been hanging out there all
week and goofing off and backing the
thing and so i come out and go hey
what's up and i throw out like 300 on
the table and i'm going 50 you know and
i'm winning
and then and he looks at me and he goes
are you going to [ __ ] around are you
going to gamble
and that was his way so are you ready
and dude i started batting that shoe i
walked out of there with 18 [ __ ]
hundred dollars [ __ ] threw him a
hundred [ __ ] tip but he said are you
like afraid of the gamble are you he
just looked at me he was just kind of
you're gonna gamble you're gonna [ __ ]
around like no this gamble and i took
that as let's go and that would have run
at you got [ __ ] 1800 walked the [ __ ]
out of there and that was the end of it
but you're right never gave it back but
i mean yeah you're gonna gamble what are
you doing a little catch a rising start
there no no that was many years ago yeah
man it's a fun place yeah but i think i
would i think it was bigger yeah no they
don't go after a certain limit but they
used to have an old i would go up there
and make i would double the salary i
would make more gambling the salary yeah
first of all the the slot machines are
from 1920. jesus [ __ ] handle those
things you stand on there for 15 minutes
you win the [ __ ] jackpot and then on
saturdays they have the money that spun
around oh yeah and i'd go in there with
the old coked up lynch sweater
you're attracted like
i'd wear one of those jackets that
acidic jews wear everything sticks to it
pennies [ __ ] dollar bills those
acidic jackets they're built like that
they're a magnet for anything [ __ ]
coins diamonds they called them the
herety by the way that's what they got
they called the i was on over in israel
they call those guys with the dark cats
and the [ __ ] big caps in the and the
the twirly things what's the name
they're called the herrera how radio
i'm not kidding you have like 10 kids
they have like they have huge families
over in israel
they're i'm not even joking no yeah they
don't believe in birth control yeah it's
the herety bunch it's the name of the
name of the group you're like no but
they did when you go to israel there's
huge there's like you know i've never
seen anything they've got families with
10 kids in them they're all about like
you know
it's amazing how you feeling brother you
okay you're good i'm really super high
you're not super high i want you to talk
to me what's the matter you weren't the
same i came in here you got something on
your mind what is it what you acting on
a [ __ ] half moment up no i've had a
good day if adrian had a son you'd be
[ __ ] adrian from rocky look at he
acted no i'm just super [ __ ] hungry
right now do you miss this [ __ ] six
days
i missed you [ __ ] unless you do
but you sit there at home like that
[ __ ] schmuck some guy came up to me
like you please have to take it easy on
me i go call him he's been home since
friday [ __ ] morning he hasn't left
the house let me take it easy on him
he's 26. where were you just at i was in
love with nick over at [ __ ] cleveland
tremendous oh dude [ __ ] drink dude
that's one of that [ __ ] hamburger
league you would have gone crazy you
would have gone crazy what did they have
on it the the meat it's like 90
restaurants in the country that get usda
meat direct from [ __ ] the united
states yeah like the cuts of meat they
get are off the [ __ ] chain like he
was she took me to the bag is look at
this the pink the red oh my god lee
you're gonna see like a puerto rican's
[ __ ] if i have like dark skin on the
outside if you look inside that hole
it's pink as that
oh my god lee this [ __ ] meat
is delicious that whole club i had an
eight-ounce patty with no because i
wanted to taste the meat i thought
you're still talking about [ __ ] they
gave me the roma tomatoes lee
we forget we give up sunshine and warm
weather but we miss out on the taste of
meat
we miss out on produce that's really
good because the produce that's grown in
california is tremendous we just don't
get none of it yeah that gets shipped to
florida and everywhere everywhere else
that's amazing yeah tell them what
happened uh for lunch with the italian
place
oh my god i went to i went to this
[ __ ] place right it was 16 below
right you know it's [ __ ] always cold
in cleveland so i go
thursday when i get there i get to
thursday afternoon i go for a walk in
the night but it's like five degrees i
gotta jump into a coffee shop i gotta
join my pocket you know i can't smoke in
the room
so i take the coffee as fake and i go
behind the coffee shop but the coffee
shop is connected to an italian
restaurant a [ __ ] dive
right people in there you know all
[ __ ] up
i go i smoke a joint back there i put
the half and join the window you know
leave it for the mouse
but i roll another joint friday which
you can't even meet i was already set i
was gonna go back to uh
the hotel and have a piece of salmon
right
and i said let me go for a walk get my
appetite smoking number well i go behind
the [ __ ]
i get a coffee and i go buy anything
it's freezing
i go behind the spot but when i walk
past i'm looking at the menu and they
got spicy sicilian style calamari and
shrimp
over pasta oh that's good i got it i got
it i got it yeah it sounds good that
sounds delicious i go around behind the
building i'm smoking this [ __ ]
this dude and all some palmer doors open
up and it's the kitchen managing the
black cook
it's like man we can smell that [ __ ]
inside that
and the one guy looks like he goes joey
dears god dad close that door what are
you smoking we start [ __ ] smoking i
go listen what's going on with that
spicy puppy
he goes i'll make it special for you i
go put it over whole wheat pasta save
the bread because he said because i got
some crispy [ __ ] bread i just got put
some butter on that [ __ ] that's
the best i said i gave up bread for
lunch just hit me with whole wheat pasta
and [ __ ] a water
and he threw me a tremendous salad
i bought them both beers
and i had this dish how much
16 bucks 22. that's not bad
two beers and a [ __ ] dish i couldn't
finish it yeah i couldn't finish it i
had to cheat and eat all the shrimp in
the calamari
but think about that
something like that what's that cost you
here cost you 12 just for the [ __ ]
beer here yeah you're saying you got one
sub and it was 20 something what today
we went yeah whatever we got 26 for two
subs a regular and a [ __ ] foot long
that [ __ ] jersey mics on a cookie and
two drinks was 26 dollars
and you got clams and shrimp and two
beers and two beers with 20 [ __ ] two
that's what i'm talking about this is
what we give up
by not living in the midwest we give up
those you know going for it's like when
you go to houston texas and you go eat
mexican food your head explodes and you
get the check unless you go to chewie's
or something you know something attacks
max that gentiles go to but if you go to
one of those things on kirby one of
those mexican places where they give you
a cup with booze to open up with
the the [ __ ] platters is 6.99 and
they give you nachos and a salad and the
guy comes over with the [ __ ] violin
and plays music with the mexican with
the green card you know you spent that's
why more people go out to dinner in
houston texas anywhere else in the
[ __ ] country yeah because for 40
dollars a family eats yeah that's great
[ __ ] family eats you know
you got to think of that dad that's why
i like you i mean
you get it's so funny you live here you
operate here but you know you hit the
road you go to minneapolis you go out
thinking wow it's cheap it's like dirt
cheaper whatever wherever you're at
you're right and you're like oh my god i
[ __ ] get it i [ __ ] get it you know
we got an interesting letter from some
guy in the law school and the law
and he was talking about you know to
talk to lee and his girlfriend i never
thought about how they regulate medical
school in california but they don't
regulate law school
and they they they want latinos and
blacks they encourage you we don't give
a [ __ ] what you do get in there yeah and
they they [ __ ] have all these lawyers
now they have an abundance of lawyers in
that language what does it do it brings
the opening calls down
so instead of making 140 with the
national averages
for a guy out of law school now they're
making 60 70 and they're fighting for
their lives a bunch of barracudas it's
like trying to sell weed in california
being the lawyer yeah you know i mean
that's what's kept half of them alive at
200 of pop go into a lawyer open up get
look at the [ __ ] licensing and [ __ ]
like that i mean if i was a lawyer i'd
hustle you gotta hustle i'm not talking
about chasing them you just got a house
you gotta get out there and you gotta do
what you gotta especially when you're
getting started you know all the time
you know you develop your reputation
cases will come to you but i mean you're
right you gotta hustle out there there's
too many guys i mean that's why the
world's so [ __ ] because it's run by
lawyers and lawyers make these [ __ ]
laws and have you know the the the the
litigation
you know in this country is [ __ ]
ridiculous because the lawyer lobby is
so [ __ ] powerful
i mean they're the guys wrong phone
again imagine charging 400 an hour 500
an hour
that's what they [ __ ] charge they get
on the phone
that's 100 phone call they charge you 15
[ __ ] minutes yeah [ __ ] a
[ __ ]
quarter
[ __ ] quarter a phone call doug for
what [ __ ] sports phone
so you [ __ ] youths don't
remember sports phone you get your bill
and there was two thousand dollars in
the sports phone with a dime a call how
much was it called 49 cents a call yeah
and you'd be staying up all night to see
if hawaii won
man we need hawaii to come through
that's the last game [ __ ] we got
hawaii then we go buy an eight ball
how's that we'll leave it to life
what's up lisa yeah what's going on what
plans you got for the week what's going
on with you sitting there like a [ __ ]
struts
even though i love you what's happening
i don't got any plans i mean we're doing
this again this week okay
and uh that's it what are you doing mama
this weekend no she's going to vegas
with her cousin to see what for her
cousin's birthday oh jesus christ i'm
not going though [ __ ] no how did you get
out of that they asked you didn't it
uh-huh oh sure yeah they want to ask
daddy warbucks to come and jump up and
down with them you said [ __ ] that
yeah man's man i can't go to vegas right
now no i'm gonna have to share a room
with two broads what am i crazy i go to
vegas just to get my dick sucked and my
balls licked like biggie anyway
right or wrong who goes to vegas with
two broads to share a whole term unless
you're in the middle i'm learning like
this like this [ __ ] knobbing whopping
spit with the other one
like a doctor but you can't do that with
mexican chicks don't have a [ __ ]
heart attack nobody will bring that
cousin you know what i'm saying but
that's good how did you get out of it
what'd you tell her i just
it's just her cousin's birthday they
didn't wanna what are they gonna do
interrupt i don't know they're going a
couple shows they're gonna go eat
they're only there for like a couple
days they're they're just it's a quick
trip i don't want to be in the room with
her cousin and
like wanting like no because it's just
those two or yeah just them too oh yeah
you're learning no you ain't covering
that thing over there be the [ __ ] odd
man plus i just like to gamble and i
just well i don't want a bunch of stupid
[ __ ] yeah they don't want to do this and
go to circuses and [ __ ]
you ain't got time to see him you're a
jew
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] no they're gonna go
to clubs it's crazy like i would never
wait in line for a club don't worry
about nothing hopefully [ __ ]
something will happen they'll never go
back
hopefully paul will call you two in the
morning and say i'll never come back to
this again that's how you look oh she
will that'll happen yeah you go to vegas
and yeah
vegas isn't for everybody but everybody
thinks they belong at least once
the vegas
vegas right back when the [ __ ] dunes
were still [ __ ] standing and you're
out there and you got the [ __ ] sam
and the outlaws there they hold you over
for a third week cause you're selling on
every show you're going to the olympic
gardens every night hanging in there
walking there with billy i don't know
why wedding all the stinking comes
around you get moved to the vip room
what's the olympic garden that's not is
that the big big big one i don't even
know no no that's that's that's the one
i mean that's that is that still there
but yeah it's still there but that's
probably the last time i went to a strip
club you and aaron hey you come in four
o'clock in the morning hey there she is
you know dude back in the day it was
crazy but i'm just saying
yeah i've done vegas now i go to vegas
and i let eleanor kerrigan and steve
simone drag me to church on sunday going
all right and then the priest comes out
like elvis then
when i went to vegas but i did big from
yoga for four days in a row like a
[ __ ] nut bag just to get away from
[ __ ] people just not to get out there
i'm telling you i was trying to you know
anything but go hang out with you know
the the the masses you know i probably
have not been in the strip club
i am 52. yeah it's been years
i'm gonna be honest with you guys last
time i walked into a strip club it's
probably 99 in cleveland at the improv
across they give you passes to go get
free lunch and you're going to have a
prime rib and you're eating this [ __ ]
prime move that looks like that [ __ ]
pink meat
who the [ __ ] wants to eat when some
chick is dancing with flapjack titties i
think i went in there one time
and then in 98 i went to a [ __ ]
toronto
and that was the last time i went awol
in the strip club
that i had to go back to the club and
get a draw and go back
oh really yeah there was a chick that
was letting me bite her pubic hairs and
lick her [ __ ] and [ __ ] she was beautiful
and every time she'd come to me i just
wanted a test i'd bite her [ __ ] pubic
hair and then one time i just tongued
her clinton she left it there i said i'm
gonna be here till two i'm coming right
back with a box of tic tacs and a pocket
full of cash
i came back and i ran over it i was like
400 pounds i ran to that hollywood land
boris the magician that's when boris had
the [ __ ] club with his jew [ __ ]
cousins and [ __ ] you got to sleep with
the cousin's house in the basement and
he drove hookers around he'd wake you up
for four in the morning i got one that
got hit by a car
she's running the discount she's sucking
you guys think i'm [ __ ] kidding you
you guys think i'm [ __ ] kidding you
[ __ ] boris's cousin listen you went
to toronto and you had to stay they were
[ __ ] jews till the end lee lee they
refused to pay for a hotel room three
comics had said we're leaving
so the one week at the one club in
toronto you stepped you slept on top of
the bar
in a two-man [ __ ] apartment with a
key on your door and [ __ ] and you they
gave you towels they refused to play for
a hotel
they refused
then when you went to the other club
like an hour from toronto you slept at
the aunt's house in the basement but the
cousin was [ __ ]
he was half retired but he drove hookers
thursdays fridays and saturdays yeah
well they did like this crazy stuff yeah
and he would knock on your door listen i
got one that said she'll suck your dick
for half price it was always a story and
you're like listen i'm only getting
[ __ ] 500 for the week i gotta get
back over the border you weren't making
any money that's why the guy hired you
he hired mc he hired mc slash features
the headline
this is the nightmare but the one night
the guy brought a stripper in that got
beat the [ __ ] up like i ran the woman
she didn't want to go to the hospital
and he's like you know she'll suck your
dick she just needs [ __ ] money to get
bandages
i'm like are you [ __ ]
did you need to do
with the guy
the guy beat her up and ran over over ah
dude that's horrible it was horrible
they had a good they were fired and he
was [ __ ] so he didn't even know what
to do he's like i don't know what to do
do i go to a pharmacy
she had been beat up and this chick
still wanted a sudden dick she looked
like [ __ ] gladiator after one of
those beatings and she still wanted to
suck my dick for the small 20.
like she wanted 60 for the night it was
a [ __ ] nightmare and i remember
thomas toronto huh yeah he kept is that
gig still there
no boris had a locked door nobody goes
to that [ __ ] he was booking [ __ ]
slash mc features the headline the only
you know he fired danny kelly
fire he fired danny kelly he fired a
couple people a couple people quit
because the money was 600 a week two
weeks to headline he kept you for two
weeks i used to do those coconuts gigs
down in florida it was 125 a night and
you had to eat the [ __ ] people yeah
yeah you see the people you say hey come
on look at me and i believe he has you
know what's up lee look at you looking
at the [ __ ] screen like you know
yeah look at this when we talk
[ __ ]
you're not high
well you know how you know you're the
[ __ ] master of disaster i've been
telling you that for [ __ ] years
you're
you don't give yourself enough credit
that's why i [ __ ] get pissed off who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah it's just it's some crazy that's
the last time i lost my mind this strip
club
but the best
one time when i was
living in boulder
kathy's mother kathy my ex-wife the one
who hates me
i was living
with her sister and her husband i was
renting out the downstairs
and my wife calls at the time she's my
girlfriend she calls me at like 9 30 and
she goes hey man
your friends just called you sabatino
and tommy roose on this other guy
they flew into denver stapleton on a
[ __ ] two day
they left jersey went to vegas
and then in vegas they got coked up and
they said we're out here we might as
well go see coco
and these guys had loot danny bianculo
danny bunculo was one of those guys
danny calls into the podcast
and i take a [ __ ] cab i call them i
call them back at the airport they're at
the [ __ ] airport i gotta pay for them
like where are you
they go take a cab we'll pay for it
we'll meet you at the airport i get to
the airport they left
they left like 200 miles with a [ __ ]
guy waiting for me the guy wait they
gave him like 500 to wait for me and
they give me two with a note go to
shotgun willie's
we go to shotgun willie's they were in
there they got a whole table control
they're in there throwing hundreds they
each got an ounce of blowing them i'm
not [ __ ] kidding you
i go listen guys i need a bum we go back
to the hotel room
they give me a few [ __ ] bumps we go
back to shotgun willie's
i ate somebody's ass somebody sucked my
dick it was horrible we went back to the
hotel we got so paranoid we hit the coke
and the tissue paper things and the wall
yeah and the next one they all got up
and they're like cokes
we're leaving like they got out you know
like when you wake up [ __ ] in your
reality they were in denver after
sleeping 12 hours they were in denver
they're like how do we get to denver
it's like we're going home like you want
the blood like no keep it
i go in there there's like an ounce in
three quarters i call my wife like
listen i got the girl i go i got a
mountain three quarters
come get me this is
this before i got locked up this is 86
the beginning of 87.
i call her up
they leave me like 200 bucks these guys
i call her up i go can you meet me and
i'm taking a cab to a cheap hotel
i take the cab to a cheap hotel
i call up she goes i can't meet you i
can't go out there but save some of the
coke we'll sell it i had no money at the
time guys
and an ounce and three quarters they
left me one rock with a little bit of
powder
they were like this is the tail end of
aquila we bought two weeks ago like
these guys were crazy wow
yeah they give me the guy checking to
this hotel but i'm getting paranoid and
i'm looking out the window and i see
that every 10 minutes a car pulls in and
another car pulls in another car pulls
in so now i'm getting paranoid so i take
a gallon of water and i take one of the
coke rocks and i throw it in there to
see how long it takes the rocks to
dissolve
now i'm hearing drills and i'm hearing
jaws oh [ __ ] so in my mind they're
coming to the ceiling
i start [ __ ] snorting like there's no
tomorrow lee i'm doing bumps
i'm in the bathroom on my hands and
knees doing coke it's all over the
bathroom floor finally i got like an
ounce left and i dump it down the
[ __ ] toilet and flush it
i start doing the coke that's around i
look out there after eight four hours
there look at the window it's an atm
machine
like a bank with the people that go to
make deposits i thought it was the fbi
switching cars on me now i'm in front of
the toilet
for six hours it was little yellow spots
where the coke had just flushed and
stick to the side i was had my hand in
the toilet and i would take these things
and put them in my nose but then there
was a gallon of water that had thrown a
coke rock in
now i'm down i'm jerking off i'm you
know it's 12 hours let's start drinking
that water i forgot all about it ah i
started drinking the water and i lost my
voice i couldn't talk until it's like
let me get some shout outs and get the
[ __ ] out of here in a couple minutes
jesus man oh my god true stories bro
radcliffe yates cody lerner i love you
[ __ ] rory oliver jameel haddad
joe varela don't make me find out your
isis jamil
and cuba justin seeley greg and lynn i
love you up there i'm thinking about you
and listen somebody in uh
indianapolis gave me a great [ __ ]
picture of oscar robinson black and
white authenticize his autograph [ __ ]
i mean just the picture i gotta get a
frame and put it in the office
you didn't put a card in there with your
name can you please hit me up on
facebook
or on gmail and talk to me and there's
something in there that you put in there
so only you'll know
so please get back to me my brother was
a beautiful [ __ ] president all right
don't forget i'm at the sacramento punch
line this thursday friday saturday
and thursday march 19th i need you guys
to put your vcr tell your grandmother
your priest everybody turn on comedy
central this is not happening
we need the [ __ ] numbers [ __ ]
it's me and ari alone all right oh nice
and you're aware this weekend i'm in
minneapolis
i'm gonna house the [ __ ]
comedy there in the mall of america
tremendous hotel at that restaurant they
have the best
mushroom barley cream soup that you will
ever [ __ ] have dude in life
the the asabu go there that
little joint that little truck yeah
tremendous and when you come back if you
tell them what you want at eight o'clock
i'm gonna come back in twelve have it
ready for me the guy i'll have it i
still got their cards one of them
bartenders there opened up his own place
and he goes when you come back i'm
taking you up there and anthony spena
[ __ ] left me a message this week
beautiful man that he is cause i kept
calling him he's somewhere in [ __ ]
beirut walking the hills
something you know these people go to
[ __ ] another country and they walk and
they turn their cell phone off here and
i'm trying to call him i couldn't get
him and he finally sent me an email so
he heard the podcast he sent us his love
so
shout out to my main man anthony smith
these mushrooms hitting you oh yeah oh
yeah i got the tail end i got the
giggles and [ __ ]
let's turn off the lights and put on
animals lee what do you think and we'll
sing we'll put on some pink floyd what
do you think okay and just to see how it
feels lee you never did mushrooms with
the lights
okay put on pink floyd dogs dogs sure
you want to see if we can do it live and
we can put it on tv i'll do whatever you
want to do if you can put on the tv that
even better show these [ __ ] people
what you're all about lisa yeah you know
when you tell these story like and the
other time i lost my mind i was at the
[ __ ] halfway house jimmy schubert
this was my second time you know you
tell me those stories bro and i cringe i
mean you just talk about you i mean i've
been in it i mean i'm so glad i haven't
done it in a number of years but i mean
you i know that feeling where you're
just oh you just gotta go to the [ __ ]
bed dude get some sleep walk it off
crazy [ __ ] but man her stories bro i
just kind of cringe i i personally
cringe because you just remind me i'm in
the halfway house i'm a month away from
getting married and i'm selling blow
with two hands at that what's the name
in the band
pink floyd you [ __ ]
dogs i'm selling blow at the halfway
house everybody gets paid on friday now
i'm at this before you put dogs on lee i
am
you know i go to prison i get out guys
and when you go to prison you learn all
these [ __ ] scamps and i got out and i
ran them all
but the main money maker i was selling
blow to get married but the main money
maker i was don't put it on yet
the main money maker was uh
loan sharking to the infix
because you had to pay your rent that's
how they got you you got to pay your
rent on thursday nobody gets paid till
friday
so if you didn't pay rent on thursday
you couldn't go out for the weekend
so they borrowed the rent to pay the
rent on friday comes so they would have
to pay the rent two weeks in advance
they didn't make that type of money
to go out those two weeks and then get a
road going you couldn't leave the house
unless you paid the rent
so i would go up to him and say listen
to 75 i'll give you 75 for 104.
until friday and they all went for it
nobody ever gave me a hard time 75 or
104 for 104 on friday so i'll pay the
rent for you once you choose i'm gonna
get i'm gonna give it to you for three
points over the vic because i had like
30 40 [ __ ] guys plus i had guys
borrowing a nickel
for 7.50 just 10 payments or 75 dollars
i was
just you know i was at my i was i was
buying stolen stuff i was getting rolex
watches
this isn't halfway i'm in bctc in bold
and i'm running this [ __ ] i'm running
i'm putting coke in the ceiling with a
scale and i remember one day the council
was in and the bag went everywhere there
was little coke rocks all over the
carpeting and she's like what's going on
with your ceiling and where they're
dying if she picks up one of these
things and tastes it she's going to go
[ __ ] bananas but why would somebody
normally pick up something white and
taste it
but i'm at the halfway
i'm five mil i got out of i got out of
that
prison in february it's march april may
june july i got a more conned
they got me on level four which means i
could come in at midnight i could drive
and i don't have to tell them where i am
every hour and i got weekend furloughs
and they call the house where i'm
furling and then they test me for
alcohol and drugs when i come back i got
them conned
i'm probably making six seven eight
grand selling mitsubishi eclipses
and i'm probably making another five or
six slinging coke and half the coke i
was stealing and this is in the halfway
this is in the house you haven't even
been fully integrated into the society
i'm driving yeah you know i'm doing the
whole thing i would wake up in the
morning i would run two miles that's how
i got precise in my heels i'd come back
i change i go to the harvest i get a
swiss granola and the harvest iced tea
and i drive to 104th and thornton that
was my day bam and i'd be there the best
[ __ ] sale and then i'd go home and
i'd wear out coke and i had people
waiting for me that and then again if a
half a gram was 50 they're in prison
they know that you have to pay
so i would charge them ten dollars for
the coke extra you want to front it
that's good but that's 60. no problem
bro give me three grams they would pay
because they just wanted to have it
and one night i got like a [ __ ] half
ounce and after i didn't have to be back
till midnight it's 10 o'clock i go to
104th and thornton but i go to one of
those places where it's no you bring
your own booze
and but they top that completely naked i
hook up with a korean girl
i got a couple lap dances next thing i'm
like oh you do blows she's doing lines
oh my god after that i mean her ass
soy sauce everywhere i just sucked up
[ __ ] [ __ ] dry she had fake tits she
had blonde hair like streak snare
i tore this [ __ ] chinese chick up to
pieces man i remember jerking off the
whole drive home like the [ __ ] was so
good you're just jerking off all over my
suit i was
i was coming on my shirt and wiping and
tucking it back in my pants that's how
good the [ __ ] was i was hit with the i
gave her all the coke i went home with
bunny rabbit ears
i gave her all the coke all i had left
bunny rabbit oh yeah both pockets were
empty she sucked me driving [ __ ] i
sucked up [ __ ] korean [ __ ] for
[ __ ] an hour i got back to the
halfway house at 5-2 i remember pulling
up and all the invicts in the windows
jumping up and down like because you
made it because i made it back and i had
coke on the trunk and i remember always
searching i'd bring the coke in like
nothing this is just a different [ __ ]
world man and then now look at this now
we're [ __ ] legit people
hit it lee
put it put it let me go up to the guitar
solo go like to a minute you wanna hit
the lights no no go to the minute dad we
just want to see what you got okay so
great story by the way man [ __ ]
tremendous [ __ ] you're sitting you got
goosebumps yeah we're still on the right
side of the grass been through all that
[ __ ] you know [ __ ]
kick it up speed it up leader one minute
i think a little more a little more
a little more
a little more
a little more
a little
more a little more
right there
your camera on the [ __ ] screen leo
yeah
oh [ __ ]
it's not even moving nothing's happening
that's the cover of that [ __ ] arm
look at the pig flying over the [ __ ]
shoots look it looks like cleveland
look at that [ __ ] place
break out one of those cookies i got one
over here let's eat some [ __ ] cookies
and shoot let's see the devil coming
if we're gonna go deep let's go [ __ ]
deep it's over it's monday night here
los angeles
the [ __ ] church we're making it
happen [ __ ]
look at lee looks like a pilot like he's
about to land the [ __ ] plane in the
hudson river
it was david gilmour's birthday maybe
three or four days ago the guy that's
playing the guitar on this
this to me is one of the best [ __ ]
solos
i could feel his [ __ ] soul
kick it up lee kick it up kick it up
you're killing me
oh shitley
i just wanted you to know [ __ ]
i can feel those mushrooms [ __ ]
letting me know i still got another one
guys you can't walk on one leg you know
can't fly on one wingman [ __ ] it ain't
nobody doing nothing tomorrow
lee ain't [ __ ]
no
sure you are don't worry about nothing
here we go lee
another mushroom sure
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
now we were really really tripping right
now like heavy duty acid tripping yeah
you're done this is sucking you in and
his first line right there when you
[ __ ] feel it
it's all over like you had his [ __ ]
scrambled eggs after this listen to the
line
you hear that bass drum at your
heartbeat
tremendous yeah
ain't much to [ __ ] say after that
[ __ ] thank you for coming out to
the church jimmy schubert you're at
minneapolis this week yeah i'm in
minneapolis tomorrow of america man and
then next week then i'm going i'm going
to do the mad house in san diego i like
going down to that club and then i'm
going to be uh then i'm hitting vegas
i'm doing brad garrett's room and then
i'm closing off uh with the new hour i'm
gonna be doing it at flappers in burbank
there on the second third and uh the
third and fourth of uh april yeah so
you'll be able to shout out here to get
some people done oh man are you kidding
me dude i'd love it joey it's great
seeing you again man thanks for having
me on looking around here at the church
get a little crazy it was a little
unauthorized tonight but [ __ ] it
that's why you can hang out with us if
not you can watch [ __ ] eyewitness
news with diane
what's up with you lisa what do you got
crack-a-lacking
i'm really [ __ ] up good good that's
what they want you that's all i got
cracker lacking right now i'm happy you
[ __ ] did this i'm happy everything's
all right
well that's pretty cool like you it's
just you and ari on that show yeah it's
very good it'll be interesting to see
what they would they captain because i
was there when they were when is that
again joey when's that show next
thursday night this is not happening
it's a season finale so it's just two of
us
and i tell a story about this lady who
took care of me after my mother died
it's it's weird how
you go to these parties and people tell
you your friends and when you die
i'll see people that i know are mutual
and they won't even bring [ __ ] up and
i'm waiting for them to go hey man
remember something you see call the ball
after you have a dream come in with carl
you bump into him he tells you a
different [ __ ] story it's like when
you bump into lenny clark yeah after
about 10 minutes you're going to that
time in chicago
yeah
so uh
what was i talking about
i'm not sure i mean what was i talking
you were talking about um
you bumping the guys got their stories
but oh this is not happening and uh
you know i'll tell you how they were
good friends but you know it
besides that some people you'll see and
they won't mention sam
and you know they were tight with sam at
the end of the night you go back to your
room and go that was weird like he
doesn't exist i'm the type of guy if i
had a good friend i honor that man are
you kidding me dude let me tell you
something he put so many cool moments in
my life and i got you know it was a
lifetime ago man he's been dead 23 years
but man it was a great time in my life i
don't i mean i look good i learned about
comments and i learned about comedy from
the [ __ ] best and you're doing it at
the [ __ ] top of your game and you're
gonna buy you're torn through america
and you get the outlaws of comedy and
you're living this dude it was amazing
and to get from there to here and
finally figure it out for myself and
start to be doing that for you know it
there's just it's a long journey but
it's worth every step of it it's a you
know it's a it's a i believe i find
myself thanking god every day that you
know you're still
still doing it man i'm still doing it
but it's funny how i
this lady was a friend of my mom's when
my mom helped out
in 1915 when my mom died in 1979 this
lady made a promise to my mom that she
was gonna take care of me and she took
care of me for six [ __ ] years pretty
much you know
from uh 79 to 84 she gave me 200 a week
and then it became something after like
three years i would just say give me an
eight ball of coke i'll sell it because
she sold coke 113th and fifth avenue and
she was a great lady i love her and i
[ __ ] her up at the end and i always it
was a guilt thing for me that's why i
told the story so right you know ari
does those storyteller shows hopefully
this is the second season we'll get you
on i'm sure oh great man i'd love it
whatever yeah ari's doing great they got
the [ __ ] billboard lee what's up wake
up snap out of it
look at the shape of you yeah i love you
guys we'll see you wednesday or tomorrow
night or whatever the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's how
stoned i am on the mushrooms i forgot to
talk about my favorite [ __ ]
people in the world my sponsors let's
open up with [ __ ] honor okay for
example today i had it today is my upper
body and but today i wanted to try
shroom tech so i said i'm going to see
how i feel this guy doesn't really want
she wants you to do cardio opposite your
weightlifting schedule so if you look in
the daytime he wants you to do cardio at
night opposite two times a week by
itself
if you have if you have a [ __ ] up
schedule he doesn't mind if you do the
cardio after your workout so today's a
heavy workout heavy benches i did
benches for like sets of four and five i
got a spotter then i did uh uh close
grip bench presses then i did [ __ ]
bent over rows heavy with 135 just
because i'm an older guy
for me that's [ __ ] heavy
but you have to do five sets of six and
i added five pounds and ten pounds and
then you have to do pull downs you have
to do shrugs you have to do upright rows
you have to do curls and tricep
extension and then you do a bunch of
setups it's a big day yeah i put a big
guy i took a 15 pound weight and just
did a bunch of [ __ ] sit-ups and then
after that i said [ __ ] i might as well
do the [ __ ] cardio thing i did 40
minutes i burnt a lot dog that [ __ ]
thing at 20 minutes i had burned 250
[ __ ] calories doing
20 seconds flying and i reached all the
way to 10
the 10.1 like 10 what 10.1 speed like
you know you go like oh i don't look at
this i went all the way up to the top
and then back to you so you do 20
seconds and all you can then 40 seconds
of 3.2 yeah yeah i gotta make myself do
that [ __ ] on the road all the time but i
did it with schumtek oh yeah
from [ __ ] on it gave me some
tremendous you know when i left that for
40 minutes i can be honest with you guys
today i'm not sure
and i walked home i walked there and
back and i still had some energy shroom
takes a [ __ ] tank you know take it
from me i got no [ __ ] cardio at all
dude i take the whole package i i love
that product that's a great [ __ ] you
know what i'm a community on the road
they make these packets they make the
day packet yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's totally prime accountant
i'm telling you man that stuff is great
when you're flying and you're moving
around a lot you usually you lose
minerals when you fly there's radiation
on the planes they got some good [ __ ] go
to honor.com right now save ten percent
open up at the alpha brain open up with
the primal care package do what the [ __ ]
you want get ten percent off use the
code word church boom there you go
c-h-u-r-c-a just in case you're [ __ ]
stupid i need you to get the ten percent
off
also
they got to stay on a program where they
mail it directly to your house no
offense of you [ __ ] a momo iron
dragon tv for you martial arts
enthusiasts
martial arts i'm sure they don't take
offense to that who gives a [ __ ] when
they take offense this is the church of
what's happening that's right you can't
take a joke take a shower remember jesus
was a jew anyway and he made a comeback
in three days you called me that we we
talked early and then you called me back
at like 10 and
as soon as i picked up
i went hey buddy anyone remember jesus
was a jew and then you just said if like
it was like a 30 minute 30 second
conversation you just hung up yeah sure
these people forget everybody thinks
jesus is a catholic there's no [ __ ]
way they say that to you to make us feel
guilty we work from strength the church
of what's happening now works from
strength jesus was a jew they killed him
because he kept winning at poker
okay and then they took him down they
killed him and he made a comeback in
three days he would have made the tube
but they broke his foot
and that's the only reason he could push
the [ __ ] rock and then what'd he do
he came back and he disappeared that's a
jew dog catholics don't they sit around
they go to church on sunday they ate the
cookie
they feel [ __ ] go let's crack open
that peanut butter god man no no no no
no you don't need a cookie
you know wait wait i want to point
something out well you know that you're
too high when joey is no
i know you do i got an anarchy peanut
butter [ __ ] cookie
that'll [ __ ] kill you you understand
me anarchy is [ __ ] rocking and
rolling there's 140 milligrams
of animal thc we'll split this three
ways no no
i was talking to some guy last night he
said he had one of those
hard candies that were like five
milligrams each i was like
five milligrams
i was like
if that does anything to you
what's what's going on with what's it's
like the edible joe rogan gave you
nothing happened do you
yeah they were loving that nothing
nothing you want to do this last
mushroom tablet no thing
wait thank lisa we got this three ways
just out of it i'm cool right now thank
you wait what do you mean you're cool
what do you got to do tomorrow morning
huh
i am dragging tv listen ufc is great
bellator is great but sometimes you want
to see the origins of this [ __ ] go to
iron dragon tv they're a roku channel
tremendous [ __ ] movie streaming at
all times to jet li i mean we could sit
here for [ __ ] hours and tell us what
they got you know what forget that [ __ ]
go take a look for yourself why are you
[ __ ] around you want to get into
classic martial arts you've been
thinking about it you don't know where
to start you like going to chinatown but
you're scared this is where you start
iron dragon tv dave fully don't [ __ ]
around plus he's giving you two movies
off the cuff for free we got an
earthquake here
what's the code over there
joey get two free [ __ ] movies from
lion dragon tv today it starts today
right now go get two [ __ ] movies take
a look at what they got they had all
types of little martial arts movies
current stuff old stuff classic stuff
you're wasting your [ __ ] time on the
other [ __ ] watching dumb [ __ ] movies
like that chef that this guy recommended
for all your [ __ ] regulars
you got to be a chef who does martial
arts then i can watch it on that night
listen martial arts couldn't help that
[ __ ] movie okay
if they would have killed the chick and
stabbed their heart and stuck a [ __ ]
title i wouldn't say that scene with a
martial arts fight yeah nailed it
live.com for all your vapor
and oil needs i got the best vapor pen
in the [ __ ] market they're great guys
lifetime guarantee just if you mention
the church go there right now and put
one in the box
20 off your first order oh why are we
even talking [ __ ] hit e6 the best
[ __ ] electronic cigar out there right
now hands [ __ ] down you know why
because you get 1200 [ __ ] pups for 16
[ __ ] dollars you go to 7-eleven
you're gonna buy nine you're gonna pay
nine dollars and you're gonna get three
pucks and it's gonna taste like a
[ __ ] yam's foot you know
it's cool it tastes like a little
[ __ ] douchey yeah
24 milligrams and
they also have a cigar the rocky [ __ ]
world you go to atlantic city and give
everybody cancer do what the [ __ ]
all right that's it i don't give a [ __ ]
hitistics.com what's the code yo he's
true joey's church got 20 off your first
order you dirty [ __ ] and that's
cause i love you
where are you gonna be
we're gonna be sacramento and don't
forget this is not happening and jimmy
schubert's gonna be where i need the
house of [ __ ] cards in minneapolis
comedy the house account the level
october
my wife's gonna tell me she wants to go
listen it's off they that's the first
place
ice is targeted yeah
they're gonna take over the mall bruce
willis is too [ __ ] old he can't save
us you know what i'm saying i swear
let me tell you something that movie
bombs i don't even want to know what's
going to happen that's going to be ugly
poor [ __ ]
kevin james
poor kevin james i love him like a
brother but he's got to do more [ __ ]
he's